bonjour à tous Dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre une table ronde qui
s'est tenue la semaine dernière au Sénat
une table ronde portant sur le régime
des intermittents du spectacle cette
audition se situe dans un contexte
particulier puisque le statut des
intermittents doit être renégocié d'ici
la fin de l'année au cœur des débats la
question de l'indemnité chômage
particulièrement favorable pour les
intermittents du spectacle mais qui est
là aussi pour venir compenser les
conditions d'emploi extrêmement
précairees problème le régime est
lourdement déficitaire voilà pour en
savoir plus sur les enjeux des
intermittents du spectacle je vous
propose donc de suivre cette table ronde
qui s'est tenu la semaine dernière au
Sénat rassemblant témoins et experts
notre objectif aujourd'hui est
d'instaurer un débat serein autour de
cette question de l'intermittent je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté d'y participer
il est très utile je crois de pouvoir
échanger confronter les point de vue
afin de ressortir les éléments de
constat partager et de mettre en
évidence les thèmes qui doivent encore
faire l'objet de débat
approfondis si je fais de
l'archéologie des débats sur
l'intermittence c'est pour vous rappeler
qu'alors que nous débattions et que nous
interpellions il y a quelques années
d'abord les ministres ayagon puis Renaud
deieu de
Vabre c'est le Ministre Fillon chargé
des affaires sociales qui avait par un
amendement dans une loi concernant les
affaires sociales portter le nouveau
protocole et là c'est la même chose si
un débat arrive dans
l'hémicycle il n'arrivera pas à la
commission de la culture il arrivera
devant la commission des affaires
sociales en premier regard g mais ça
regarde tellement la culture que nous
avons souhaité nous mobiliser là-dessus
alors quelques mots de l'organisation de
cette table ronde nous aurions aimé
pouvoir inviter tous les représentants
du secteur dont la connaissance du sujet
a été appréciée par les sénateurs
membres du groupe de travail cependant
afin que le débat soit audible il nous a
fallu limiter le nombre d'intervenants
je précise que des contributions écrites
que ce soit des gens présents ou absents
pourront nous nous être adressé à fait
d'être intégré au compte-rendu qui sera
publié avant la fin de l'année et nous
en avons déjà été destinataire d'un
exemple là tout de suite toujours dans
un esprit de clarté des débats il nous a
semblé indispensable de distinguer
plusieurs séquences donc la première
partie elle sera consacrée aux enjeux
elle permettra aux intervenants de nous
présenter leur analyse de la situation
et de partager leur
expertise j'insiste sur un point il est
évident que toutes les personnes ici
présent ont une très bonne connaissance
du sujet et pourrait drresser un état
des lieux complet je pense notamment aux
partenaires sociaux qui pourront bien
entendu nous livrer leur point de vue
lorsqu'ils interviendront mais dans la
limite des 7 minutes qui leur ont été
imparties la deuxième partie abordera
les mesures
d'accompagnement en effet la place du
régimes des intermittents dans les
politiques culturelles ne peut se
résumer à la présentation de règles
d'indemnisation
de chômage une fois le fonctionnement
des annexes 8 et 10 analysés il est
vraiment indispensable de comprendre
comment l'écosystème de la culture
fonctionne et comment le ministère de la
Culture et celui du travail structure
leur action en complément du régime des
intermittents enfin la dernière partie
sera l'occasion de donner la parole aux
partenaires sociaux qui auront la lourde
responsabilité de la négociation
relative à la convention d'assurance
chômage et de ses annexes
par ailleurs je voudrais simplement
rappeler que nous sommes évidemment
tributaires des agendas des différentes
personnes contactées pour participer à
cette table ronde nous avions évidemment
invité tous les partenaires sociau
représentatifs tous n'ont pas pu ou
voulu je ne sais pas se libérer comme
par ailleurs les experts de la question
de l'intermittence dans l'audiovisuel
qui est pourtant un sujet récurrent dans
les débats enfin je regrette
particulièrement l's de Pôle Emploi qui
n'a pas souhaité venir même si le
ministère du travail sera représenté la
présence de Pôle Emploi aurait je crois
été particulièrement utile pour nous
éclairer dans la deuxème partie et je
peux vous dire que les actions de Pôle
Emploi remplissent les boîtes lettes des
parlementaires puisque nombre
d'intermittents viennent plaider la
façon dont leur dossier a été débouté et
nous devenons des par buureaux d' social
c'est un peu complexe pour nous avant de
laisser la parole à nos premiers
intervenants je vous propose de regarder
une très courte vidéo de 6 minutes
réalisé par les équipes de la direction
de la communication du Sénat je les en
remercie c'est un petit travail inédit
mais nous ne pouvions pas mettre en
scène ici le temps nous étant compté
différents acteurs et donc nous avons
choisi euh que quatre intermittents
puissent se prêter au jeu des
questions-réponses dans des délais très
courts il leur a simplement été demandé
de parler de leur profession de leur
attachement au régime et de nous dire si
ce rattachement avait été choisi ou subi
et s'ils estimaient que ce régime devait
ou non évoluer je vous propose de
découvrir ensemble leur réaction pour
tout de suite entrer dans le vif du
sujet je vous
remercie ça va partir si vous permettez
madame la Présidente il y a juste un
petit regret nous n'avons pas réussi à
avoir de technicien il y en a un qui
devait
être venir faire ce petit reportage et
il n'a pas pu donc et après on a été
pris de cours pour pouvoir avoir
effectivement quelqu'un d'autre pour le
suppléer donc nous en sommes désolés
aussi bien que vous l'êtes je
pense
je m'appelle malcol conrat je joue dans
les adolescents en ce moment à Paris je
suis car Chan je joue actuellement une
pièce au Théâtre du gymnas qui s'appelle
les adulescents je m'appelle Antoine
Chenuet je suis chanteur lyrique je
m'appelle florencequin je suis
violencelliste j'ai mon statut
d'intermittente depuis je crois 1990
j'ai commencé en faisant des spectacles
pour enfants pour une compagnie qui
s'appelait éclat
théâtre des spectacles de Fab de la
fontaine et voilà grâce à ça j'ai
commencé à avoir mes premiers cachets de
de comédienne et avoir mon mon statut
j'ai une quarantaine d'années je suis
intermitant depuis que j'ai à peu près
25 ans donc ça fait une bonne ça fait 17
ans je suis indemnisé selon l'annexe 10
depuis 2 mois ces quatre dernières
années
euh j'étais j'ai eu une activité de
chanteur lyrique et en complément
j'étais aussi professeur en
conservatoire
euh à temps partiel en tant que
vacataire euh voilà pour diverses
disciplines comme la formation musicale
ou le champ Coral en 89 je suis rentrée
à l'Orchestre Régional de Bretagne et en
fait suite à mon mariage j'ai
démissionné et je me suis retrouvé
intermittente en 1996 même si on a des
gros rôles c'est très compliqué de faire
intermittence parce qu'il faut 507h
l'équivalent de 43 45 50 cachet donc une
un cachet égal une journée travailler et
aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout évident à
part si on fait du théâtre sur du long
terme là comme je fais en ce moment donc
tous les jours c'est un cachet donc si
on va jouer 4 5 mois l'intermittence on
la facile mais si les comédiens qui font
peu de théâtre et cetera j'en connais
plein qui font plus des téléfilms du
cinéma et cetera ils ont du mal à avoir
l'intermittence ces quatre dernières
années je j'ai j'ai travaillé en tant
que chanteur lyrique pour pour
différents employeurs et je n'arrivais
pas à obtenir les 507 he demandé dans la
période impartie c'est-à-dire 10 mois et
demi donc 3 années de suite j'ai raté de
peu à chaque fois le status qui
m'obligeait à avoir une autre activité
complémentaire par chance ces dernières
années j'ai pas eu de difficulté mais
c'est vrai que c'est toujours un
challenge de renouveler le statut et on
doit vraiment faire très très attention
parfois faire desé examens anticipés
pour être sûr d'avoir assez d'heur quand
on va redémarrer le statut c'est
vraiment un stress terrible parce
qu'évidemment le travail se fait de plus
en plus rare ce statut d'intermittent
qui en fait paye les jours non
travaillés une fois qu'on l'a c'est
vraiment statue formidable en revanche
c'est extrêmement difficile de l'avoir
donc ça c'est vraiment une blague qui
tournait même dans le métier on disant
tu es comédien ouais ouais je suis
comédien mais tu as les assédiques ouais
ah ouais donc tu es vraiment comédien
bien que je travaille beaucoup si
j'avais pas les assédiques je ne
pourrais absolument pas vivre de ce que
je fais parce que je suis en dessous de
1000 € par mois net j'ai regardé ma
feuille d'impôt avant de venir alors que
je je fais quand même à peu près 1300
heur par an moi je suis content de
l'avoir mais là ça faisait 2 ans que je
l'avais pas là je suis en train de
lutter pour le R voir avec cette piège
je va les réavoir et tant mieux mais
j'aurais lutté 2 ans j'aurais vécu 100
pendant 2 ans difficilement très
difficilement j'ai envisagé de changer
de métier mais quoi faire quand ça fait
depuis 90 que je fais ce métier
honnêtement je crois que c'est ce que je
fais de mieux les gens imagine que c'est
un statut très confortable parce que
quand on travaille pas finalement on a
quand même un peu d'argent mais d'abord
quand on travaille pas cet argent
s'écoule très très vite puisque c'est
244 jours d'indemnisation donc ça fait 3
mois et donc quand déjà on n pas pas
travaillé pendant un mois et demi ben ça
grignote la moitié des indemnités et il
y a toujours l'idée qu'il faut refaire
ce statut pour avoir 50 cachets en 10
mois honnêtement ça devient impossible
quoi c'est que s'il y a pas du théâtre
au milieu qui fait un un un salaire
minimum du coup on se retrouve au
théâtre avec des cachets tout petits
aussi mais 5 jours de théâtre d'affilé
ben voilà on meurt quoi depuis que le
statut est passé à 10 mois et demi au
lieu de 12 mois pour faire les 507 heur
ça VI extrêmement tendu parce qu'en fait
il y a des mois complètement vides comme
le mois d'août juillet il reste encore
un peu de choses à faire alors
évidemment les gens qui font les les
festival en classique travail au mois
d'août mais le reste du temps tout
s'arrête maintenant on est censé faire
le même nombre d'heures sur 10 mois et
pardonnez-moi l'expression on compte nos
morts c'est-à-dire que j'ai vu les gens
tomber tout le monde a entendu parler
des abus qu'il y avait et bien sûr
chaque fois qu'il y a un système
d'autant plus s'il est bien fait il y a
des gens qui essayent d'exagérer et je
pense que ce qui doit évoluer c'est
évidemment les contrôles et la manière
de de l'obtenir les gens déclaré comme
intermittent à France Télévision à Canal
plus à Radio France à M6 et cetera alors
qu'ils sont à pleintemps avec un bureau
à pleintemp ne devrait pas être
intermittent ils sont salariés mais les
grandes boîtes d'audiovisuel déc
intermittent fait des économies mais par
derrière ça met un gros trou de de
déficit dans le régime des intermittents
des acédiques donc
je pense que la réforme elle devrait se
faire là l'existence de ce statut c'est
vraiment un soutien à la culture en
général j'ai fait beaucoup de théâtre et
j'ai créer aussi mes spectacles ce qui
m'a permis effectivement de bah de
continuer à avoir ce ce statut et
surtout de créer voilà ce statut m'a
servi à créer ça change la vie ben on va
dire je peux vivre décemment juste avec
cette activité ça m'a permis moi de
pouvoir faire des chométrages pas payés
de pouvoir me
répéterhui répétition des trois/4 des
pièces de théâtre sont pas payé donc ça
m'a permis de de vivre et ou voir de
survivre et pas tout le temps de vivre
correctement mais je
remercie profondément éternellement le
système français qui est
l'intermittence alors chers amis vous
avez entendu ces mots spontanés les
questions de
rabillage vous ont sans doute fait
bondir puisque vous avez vu et je sais à
quel point il y a une sensibilité là
dessus le mot statut et bien il est
important pour les partenaires sociaux
qui contestent justement la légitimité
de ce mot statut de savoir combien il
est
spontanément cité par les gens qui ont
cette couverture de des temps de chômage
il il ne ils ne portent pas leur droit
comme un droit social de rémunération
pendant le temps où ils sont à leurs
propres activités de création et où ils
sont pas sur scène non ils disent le
statut des intermittent et nous n'avons
pas souhaité corriger ceci bien que je
sais à quel point euh vous c'était un
mot sensible pour
vous il a été repris dans les on fait
filmna pas plus queux qui on parl ah pas
du tout alors ce qui alors on va vous
donner la précision du film parce que
c'est très très important puisque la
commission innove et on nous a j'ai
souhaité que les intermittents soient
mis en scène mais on pouvait pas inviter
comme ça des gens on n'avait pas
beaucoup de temps donc on a souhaité des
petits clips et vous savez ce qu'on nous
a proposé parce qu'on est une grande
maison hein bah de faire appel à une
grande boîte de com et puis une boîte de
prod hein et puis tout ça puis une
facture avec votre argent allez soyons
généreux 5 à 10000 € et ben non on a
fait radio trottoir dans les couloirs
des des salariés du Sénat qui l'un
connaît un viéoncéliste l'autre une
actrice et tout ça et comme il y a des
caméras qui traînent ici on a fait avec
les moyens du bord et oui les gens qui
ont filmé sont des gens qui ne
connaissent rien au statut de
l'intermittence et ça vous donne une
belle photographie du live de ce qui se
passe dans la tête des gens et ça ça me
semble important aussi onentend et vas-y
Marie et la question qui leur a été
posée il s'agissait de leur rattachement
au régime de l'intermittence nous
n'avons jamais posé la question du en
utilisant le terme statut mais bien le
rattachement au régime d'intermittence
que ça soit clairement entendu voilà
voilà instructif pour tout le monde bien
allez passons les enjeux du régime des
intermittents expertise et témoignage je
donne tout de suite la parole à un
conseiller maître à la Cour des comptes
Monsieur Michel David de
vireville merci madame la Présidente je
vais limiter mes salutations contte tenu
du temps qui nous est imparti mais elles
sont néanmoins chaleureuses et destinées
à l'ensemble des participants euh je
voudrais
démarrer cette réexposition du du point
de vue de la Cour des comptes en partant
du terme de solidarité parce que je
pense que la la position de la Cour a
parfois été mal compris prise bien
entendu le le régime d'assurance chômage
dans son ensemble c'est un régime qui
est fondé sur la solidarité ce sont ceux
qui ont une activité qui cotisent et ce
sont évidemment ceux qui sont privés
d'emploi qui perçoivent les allocations
et à l'intérieur de cette solidarité
générale il y en a une plus particulière
qui concerne les précaires parce
qu'évidemment les précaires sont moins
souvent en activité ils sont plus
souvent au chômage et donc il est tout à
fait logique que quand on fait des
bilans euh fragmentés par pour des
salariés qui sont sous statut précaire
on constate que ils perçoivent plus
d'allocation qu'ils n'ont versé de
cotisation et donc que ces régimes
soient en déficit donc quand la Cour a
dit que a constaté que le régime des
intermittents était en déficit il y
avait pas là une quelque chose de
d'étrange ou de particulier c'est le cas
du régime de l'intérim de l'annexe 4
également et c'est aussi ce qu'on
constate si on prend dans le régime
général les salariés qui sont en contrat
à durée déterminé là aussi sur une année
au total l'ensemble des CDD cotisent
moins que les intéressés ne perçoivent
d'allocation quand ils sont en chômage
donc le point qui que nous avons fait
apparaître s'agissant du régime des
intermittents c'est ce qu'on observe
quand on compare précisément ces trois
ensembles de précaires que sont les CDD
du régime général les intérimaires et
enfin les annexes 8 et 10 les
intermittents du
spectacle je ne vous donnerai pas trop
de chiffres cont tenu du du temps
imparti mais je voudrais quand même vous
rappeler les chiffres s'agissant de des
allocations et des
cotisation si on prend les contrats à
durée
déterminé l'ensemble des contrats à
durée déterminé on observe que les
allocations
versées représentent deux fois et demi
le montant des cotisations
pr le montant des cotisations versé par
les
CDD les allocations perçues par les CDD
quand ils sont au chômage de fois et
demi si on prend les
inter intérimaires pardon les
intérimaires c'est de fois et demi les
CDD c'est 3,6
fois c'estàd les les intérimaires les
CDD touchent 3,6 fois plus d'allocation
qu'il ne verse de cotisation pour les
intermittents du spectacle c'est 5,2
fois ils perçoivent 5, plus de 5 fois ce
qu'ils ont versé comme cotisation donc
ce que nous avons dit très simplement
c'est que l'effort de
solidarité du régime par rapport aux
intermittents du spectacle est nettement
plus élevé que celui qu'on constate pour
les autres types de contrat précairirees
et ces trois régimes sont a priori
comparables donc premier constat c'est
cette intensité de la
solidarité mais le constat va un petit
peu plus loin si on si on regarde
comment les choses se passent de façon
plus pratique ce que l'on constate c'est
que ceux qui sont dans le régime des
intermittents vous avez vu en en
regardant les vidéos que beaucoup de
gens ont ont des contrats précaires dans
le domaine du spectacle mais n'ont pas
accès au régime des intermit
mais si on regarde ceux qui sont
intermittents pour la plupart ils
quittent leur situation de travail
quelques jours après avoir
effectué le nombre de jours nécessaires
pour accéder au
régime et de la même manière il retrouve
souvent une activité au moment où ils
ont épuisé leur
droit alors je vais pas vous donner des
chiffres mais cette analyse elle est
claire et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'elle soulligne elle soulligne que de
façon oui c'est massif elle soulligne
que le phénomène qu'on a appelé la
permittence est un phénomène qui est
répandu je dirais même qui est très
répandu c'est un phénomène dans
lequel en fait il y a une alternance
entre des périodes de chômage et des
périodes d'activité la location de
chômage étant un complément de
rémunération qui est versé pendant les
périodes où l'intéressé n'est pas en
activité vous avez vu quand on écoute ce
qui a été dit on a même évoqué des
situations qui sont des situations
évidemment encore beaucoup plus
perverses et où les intéressés sont en
permanence en activité y compris quand
ils sont indemnisés mais je n'évoquerai
pas ces questions qui sont évidemment
des des infractions à la à la
législation
alors la question que nous posons
simplement et parce que c'est notre
métier de magistrat des comptes c'est la
question du bon niveau de solidarité qui
doit être retenu c'est évidemment cette
question ça n'est pas à nous de la
trancher et comme la présidente l'a fait
il y a quelques instants c'est
évidemment à la négociation entre les
partenaires sociaux qu'il revient de de
de de chercher ses paramètres pour
autant sans guider les partenaires
sociaux il y a deux éléments qui nous
paraissent importants et qui nous
paraissent devoir être pris en
considération
euh le premier c'est qu'il nous semble
que ce qu'il faut interpeller par les
modifications qui seraiit à prendre
c'est beaucoup plus évidemment les
employeurs que les
salariés les salariés ils utilisent le
dispositif qui leur est offert c'est les
employeurs qu'il faut dissuader non pas
d'utiliser ce dispositif car la Cour des
comptes nen met pas en cause l'existence
d'un régime spécifique pour les
intermittents du spectacle mais il faut
les dissuader d'abuser de ce
dispositif alors je sais que les les
employeurs payent déjà des cotisations
plus élevées que celles du régime
général mais il nous semble que il
conviendrait peut-être d'augmenter ses
cotisations à nouveau et
surtout de les rendre
variables en fonction du de l'intensité
du recours à
l'intermittence vous voyez que ceci
aurait non seulement un effet positif
sur éidment l'équilibre financier du
régime mais ça va un petit peu plus loin
c'est que si la cotisation est
progressive avec le degré de recours on
s'aperçoit qu'au-delà d'un certain seuil
l'employeur n'a plus intérêt à recourir
à la permittence pardon à
l'intermittence il a intérêt à offrir
des contrats qui sont des contrats
définitifs et donc il y a dans cette
voie de réflexion nous semblet-il une
voie de réflexion importante la deuxième
c'est technicien
artiste
le la situation des techniciens et des
artistes quand on fait l'analyse de
façon plus détaillée on constate qu'elle
n'est pas la
même on constate que la situation des
techniciens est beaucoup plus proche de
celle de l'ensemble des précaires quand
on regarde du point de vue de la de
l'architecture de leur contrat de
travail alors que la situation des
artiste c'est une situation qui qui
justifie beaucoup plus d'un régime
spécifique et donc il nous semble que il
serait logique de réfléchir à une plus
forte différenciation du régime des
artistes et de celui des
techniciens avec une évolution du régime
des
techniciens qui qui se rapproche voire
qui converge avec celui qui est fait au
au précaire en général que ce soit dans
le cadre de l'intérim ou dans le cadre
des contrats duré
déterminé voilà de façon compacte et en
mtenant au délai que vous m'avez donné
la position de la Cour sur ce sujet très
important merci de votre clarté et
effectivement de votre respect parfait
de la montre Monsieur le Directeur
Général de lunedic Monsieur Vincent
d'Estival vous allez être au au première
loge de
l'élaboration des négociations à venir
donc nous vous
écoutons merci madame la Présidente je
m'exprimerai pas au nom des négociateurs
certains le feront dans la 3è partie de
cette table ronde euh mais voilà pour
apporter ma contribution à l'éclairage
de de votre réflexion
euh j'ai pu constater au travers du
compte-rendu qu'elle était déjà bien
avancée je voudrais dans un premier
temps revenir sur la question de
l'analyse de la compréhension de
l'équilire financier du régime des
intermittents Michel Deville disait
l'assurance chômage c'est fonctionne sur
une logique de solidarité je pense qu'il
faut être plus équilibré l'assurance
chômage c'est une assurance et c'est de
la solidarité elle répond à cette double
logique une logique d'assurance donc de
proportionnalité
entre euh les revenus qu'une personne a
pu tirer de son travail et la location
dont elle pourra bénéficier et une
logique de
solidarité cette logique de solidarité
elle se traduit dans des mécanismes de
redistribution que que Michel Deville a
évoqué euh et le principal comme il l'a
bien souligné et là-dessus je crois que
le diagnostic que fait la cour a été
longuement partagé avec l'Unedic et avec
nos nos service
d'études notre diagnostic est le même il
y a un mécanisme de redistribution
important au sein de l'assurance chômage
entre les
salariés qui sont en emploi à contat à
durée déterminée et les salariés qui
sont qui alternent emplois de courte
durée et emploi de chômage pour donner
là encore peu de chiffre mais un chiffre
important je vous rappelle que les
emplois à durée limité représentent
environ 15 % de l'emploi en France c'est
50 % plus de 50 % des allocataires de
l'assurance chômage donc on voit bien
que évidemment le risque que l'emploi
viennent à terme pour un contrat durée
limité il
est quasi certain même s'il y a des
enchaînements possibles pour un contrat
duéterminé heureusement il est beaucoup
plus limité voilà donc on a ce premier
pr mécanisme de redistribution on a un
deuxième mécanisme de redistribution au
sein de l'assurance chômage qui est de
l'ensemble de l'assurance chômage vers
les intermittents du spectacle puisque
vous le savez bien je vais pas revenir
en détail non plus là-dessus les
intermittents du spectacle bénéficie de
règles
particulières qui déroge aux règles
générales et de ce point de vuelà
peut-être par rapport à ce qu'a pu dire
Michel de Virville je partage pas tout à
fait ce qu'il a pu dire en disant il y a
parallélisme entre la situation des
intérimaires la situation des contrats
duré déterminé et la situation des des
intermittents je crois qu'il y
a les les contrats duré déterminé les
intérimaires bénéficient d'un régime
d'indéisation qui est proche très proche
de celui du régime général ce sont les
mêmes principes que les principes du
régime général et et je dirais les
intérimaires et les CDD exercent les
mêmes métiers que ceux qu'exercent
des salariés en contat dururé
indéterminée ce qui est pas tout à fait
le cas s'agissant des intermittents et
et le film La mis en valeur voilà donc
je voulais juste apporter ce petit
correctif plus de forme peut-être que de
fond alors si on a ayant posé ces
éléments de mécanisme de redistribution
comment du coup on peut analyser euh
l'équili financier des annexes 8 et 10
on connaî bien les chiffres un écart
entre les recettes et les dépenses pense
de 1 milliard d'euros 1 Millard 300
millions d'euros d'allocation
versée si j'essaie de regarder comment
finalement sont financés les 1ard 300
millions d'allocations versées il y a
une première partie
c'est le la contribution normale des
employeurs en intermittent du spectacle
c'est environ 150 millions d'euros qui
sont payés cotisation que payent les
employeurs d'intermittent comme tous les
autres
employeurs deuxième élément c'est le
mécanisme de redistribution que j'ai
évoqué entre les contrats à durée
indéterminé les autres formes de contrat
de travail celui-là est beaucoup plus
important mais il joue spécifiquement
par pour ce pour ces emploi là mais il
joue aussi pour d'autres secteurs de
l'économie on peut l'évaluer autour de
700 millions
d'euros trème élément de financement
c'est la solidarité professionnelle la
solidarité professionnelle c'est la
majoration
de contribution que payent les
employeursinmittent du spectacle et ça
représente à peu près 100 millions
d'euros quand on a additionné ces trois
composantes identifiables il reste et
c'est le chiffre qui a mis en évidence
le
rapport de vos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale il reste 320 millions d'euros
ces 320 millions d'euros au fond c'est
là aussi c'est la solidarité
interprofessionnelle qui joue mais c'est
pas une solidarité
interprofessionnelle générale comme elle
peut jouer entre C CDI et CDD intérim
c'est une solidarité
interprofessionnelle qu'on constate à
postériori comme étant l'écart entre les
différents éléments de financement que
je viens d'évoquer donc je crois que si
on veut réfléchir à cette question de de
l'équilibre financier du régime des
intermittent du spectacle il faut
évidemment et j'ai vu que dans le
compte-rendu de votre commission vous
vous faites s'interroger sur les règles
d'indemnisation des métiers concernés il
faut aussi s'interroger sur la bonne
répartition des différents niveaux de
solidarité dans le
financement de de l'assurance chômage
des intermittant du
spectacle que tout le monde convient que
c'est un dispositif important voilà
quelle est la place de la solidarité
interprofessionnelle quelle est la place
de la solidarité professionnelle Chelle
de Viville géit que il conviendrait que
cette solidarité professionnelle soit
plus importante quelle est la place
également sujet qu'on n pas encore
évoqué de de la solidarité nationale qui
me paraître aussi un sujet importantis
juste aborder en une minute deux autres
points complémentaires le premier
pour souligner le fait que depuis les
dernières réformes du régime des
intermittents du spectacle qui sont
intervenus en 2003 et
2006 la situation globale
de l'indemnisation des intermittents est
stabilisé au travers des différents
indicateurs qu'on peut avoir en terme de
nombre en terme de déséquilibres
financier en terme de répartition de
structure du revenu des intermittents
entre ce qui provient de la activité
professionnelle ce qui provient de leur
indemnisation dernier point sur lequel
je voudrais insister c'est
que la
compréhension de l'activité des
intermittents du spectacle je pense ça
pourra être abordé dans la deuxème
partie de cette table ronde relève d'un
entrecroisement de responsabilité et que
les partenaires sociaux qui négocient la
convention d'assurance chômage n'ont pas
l'ensemble des leviers entre leurs mains
que une partie de ces leviers relèvent
des partenaires sociaux au niveau de
chacune des branches et que d'autres
leviers relèvent également de la
responsabilité euh de l'État euh de la
responsabilité du législateur euh au
travers de la réglementation du contrat
de travail mais aussi au travers de tout
ce qui est politique de labellisation
conduite par le ministère de la Culture
et donc il a besoin de chercher euh une
bonne articulation entre ces différents
niveaux d'intervention euh dernier juste
pour conclure vous avez évoqué madame la
Présidente le travail que vous nous avez
également adressé de de benchmark
européen c'est un travail que nous
faisons aussi et donc on vous adressera
l'issue de cette réunion nos propres
travaux pour éclairer les vôtres merci
de votre écoute merci beaucoup alors
nous allons entendre l'université un
maître de conférence en sociologie à
l'Université de
Picardie chercheur CNRS et chercheur
associé au Centre d'études de l'emploi
monsieur Mathieu
Grégoire merci madame la Présidente
effectivement mes travaux on porté
depuis dizaine d'années sur le sur le
régime des intermittents et plus
généralement sur l'histoire des
intermittents depuis la première grève
des intermittant enfin du spectacle de
1919 et je me suis intéressé aux
différentes manières dont les qui ont
été historiquement imaginé pour assurer
une condition sociale digne à ses
salariés à l'emploi
intermittent alors j'imagine que vous MZ
pas appeler pour parler de de cette
histoire mais plus pour l'actualité de
ce ce régime néanmoins à titre de pr je
voudrais évoquer quelques enseignements
de cette histoire de plus d'un siècle la
première chose que je retiens de cette
histoire c'est que l'intermittence comme
ça a été dit par les casades
intermittents n'est pas une maladie
c'est pas une maladie du salariat dont
la seule bonne santé serait l'emploi
stable d'abord parce qu'il faut garder à
l'esprit que l'intermittence n'est pas
forcément subie tous les intermittent ne
rêv pas d'un CDI par ailleurs
l'intermittence de l'emploi est pas du
tout un phénomène
nouveau c'est un usage très ancien
notamment chez les artistes du spectacle
et les techniciens du cinéma et cette
intermittence n'a commencé à devenir un
handicap relatif
que dans la mesure où le le reste du
salariat s'est constitué les
institutions et les droits du salariat
son constitués sur la base sur le modèle
de l'emploi stable et petit à petit du
coup les intermittents sont trouvés
handicapés par le fait que leur emploi
ne correspondait pas au modèle de
protection sociale qui était construit
dans notre
pays et ce qui a été nouveau ce qui est
nouveau c'est plutôt l'accès effectif
des intermittents à l'assurance chômage
depuis les conventions inédiques de 79
et de 84 selon des dispositions adaptées
à leur caractéristiques
d'emploi donc ce dispositif est adapté
mais il ne constitue pas pour autant un
privilège
quand on compare la situation des
permanents de l'emploi stable et des
intermittents il faut toujours garder à
l'esprit que
lorsquun permanent quelqu'un en CDI
connaî une difficulté professionnelle il
tombe au chômage tombe dans
l'indemnisation du chômage lorsqu'un
intermittent connaî une difficulté
professionnelle il tombe hors de
l'indemnisation du chômage donc on voit
qu'on peut pas comparer terme à terme
des situations qui sont de fait de fait
décalé
alors je pourrais développer plus
longuement cette histoire de de l'emploi
de la protection sociale dans dans le
secteur mais il est peut-être plus utile
ici que j'insiste sur l'actualité ce que
je vais faire en suivant un petit peu le
le l'actualité des débats c'est-à-dire
les les différents apports récents à ce
à ce débat alors d'abord le
effectivement le rapport de de la Cour
des comptes c'est un un document assez
surprenant je dois dire d'une très
grande
sévérité sévérité qui me paraît assez
injustifiée en tout cas fondée sur sur
des constats très euh contestables alors
je n'évoquerai pas les maladresses du
calcul du taux de chômage dans lequel
euh la catégorie de des des
intermittents non indemnisés n'est pas
considéré comme chômeur euh et j'en
viens directement à la question du
supposé déficit des annexes 8 et 10 donc
pour la cour en 2010 le déficit du
régime des annexes 8 et 100 a représenté
1/3 de celui de l'assurance chômage dans
son ensemble alors même que les
intermittents ne représentaient que 3 %
des demandeurs d'emploi donc je crois
bien bien
comprendre cette affaire c'està-dire de
rapporter le prétendu des déficits des
intermitant qui est très stable à 1
milliard d'euros sur le déficit général
de l'assurance chômage qui était à
l'époque en 2010 de 3,2 milliards
d'euros mais vous serez d'accord avec
moi que cet indicateur n'a aucun sens
puisque l'année prochaine siin cette
année en 2 13 si comme prévu nous
arrivons à un déficit de 5 milliards
d'euros à cause de l'augmentation du
chômage il faudrait se réjouir que les
intermittents ne représentent plus que
20 % du du déficit
inversement si par bonheur le le chômage
baissa et qu'on arrivit à 1 milliard de
déficit il faudra attribuer 100 % du
déficit des intermittents de de
l'assurance de chômage aux intermittents
et on voit qu'on peut aller
à parler de 200 % si le déficit tombe à
500 millions et cetera donc plus
fondamentalement il me semble qu'il est
pas justifié une fois qu'on a qu'on a
dit ce que ce que vous avez dit tous les
deux sur la la solidarité les mécanismes
de solidarité au sein de l'assurance
chômage la question de la la solidarité
interprofessionnelle il n'est plus
justifié ni de parler de déficit ni de
parler de régime il est pas possible de
parler de déficit dans la mesure où il
n'y a pas une caisse il n'y a pas de
caisse des intermittents du spectacle il
n'y a même pas un régime des
intermittents du spectacle il y a
simplement des des règles comme vous
l'avez dit des règles dérogatoires
c'està-dire des annexes au règlement de
de l'unidic dès lors il est improbable
impossible d'arriver à une situation
dans laquelle on aurait un équilibre
dans les annexes 8 et 10 avec des
déséquilibres avec des excédents par
ailleurs le rôle d'une assurance sociale
est d'équilibrer n'est pas de faire de
profit c'est d'équilibrer les dépenses
et et les recettes de ce fait là si d'un
côté on a des excédents parce que fort
heureusement on a des salariés à
l'emploi
stable qui cré des excédents et bien on
retrouve de l'autre côté mécaniquement
par construction un décalage un sold
qu'on peut pas appeler déficit
puisque ce décalage n'est pas un fait de
gestion ce décalage est une mécanique
qui n'est d qu'au fait qu'il existe des
salariés à l'emploi stable qui cotisent
à l'assurance chômage
si on pousse le raisonnement jusqu'au
bout ça veut dire que il y aura toujours
un déficit mécaniquement tant qu'il y
aura des salariés à l'emploi stable dans
dans ce pays le l'équilibre sera atteint
le jour où tout le monde sera
intermittent donc du coup en poursuivant
en poursuivant cet objectif d'une
certaine manière ce qu'on poursuit c'est
de
dire c'est de faire comme si de faire
comme si le la caisse existait
c'est-à-dire de poursuivre au fond ce
qui est le désir du patronat dans dans
cette affaire là c'est-à-dire d'une
autonomisation de la caisse des
intermittents c'est-à-dire arriver à une
situation dans laquelle on aurait une
caisse autonome des intermittents et
dont le l'Unedic ce serait d'une
certaine manière débarrassé hors de la
sphère de la solidarité
interprofessionnelle alors il est vrai
que il y a une dynamique
d'autonomisation sous l'impulsion du du
MDEF on a plusieurs marques
d'autonomisation de de ce régime
notamment à partir de 2002 avec le
doublement des des cotisations qui est
effectivement un financement purement
professionnel qui sort de la logique
interprofessionnelle qui est celle de
l'assurance sociale alors pour autant
effectivement euh comme l'a dit Monsieur
Deville la la question est de savoir
quel est l'intensité de la solidarité
alors je vrais quand même reprendre un
petit peu plus de recul historique
c'estàdire qu'au début des années 2000
pour 1 € de cotisation on avait 8 ou 8,5
€ d'allocation à cette époque euh la
Cour des comptes avait évoqué un
scénario qui était considéré comme
radical à l'époque d'un alignement des
intermittents sur les règles de l'annexe
4 des intérimaires une simulation avait
été faite sur des données de l'année
2000 et elle aboutissait à la conclusion
suivante aligner les intermittents sur
le régime des intérimaires aurait permis
une économie de 225 millions d'euros ce
qui aurait eu pour effet à cette
époque-là en 2003 de pas passé de 8 € à
loué pour 1 € cotisé à 5,4 et comme l'a
dit Monsieur devville on est aujourd'hui
à 5,25 autrement dit on aller plus loin
que les efforts les plus radicaux
imaginés en 2003 de ce fait là je pense
qu'on peut parler davantage d'un effort
massif qui a été fait par le les les
intermittents davantage que d'une dérive
massive alors je voudrais maintenant
évoquer le rapport d'information de de
l'Assemblée nationale rédigé par
jean-Patrique Gill et les réflexions
menées ici même au Sénat dans le cadre
de votre commission alors ces travaux
ont eu parmi d'autres mérites le mérite
essentiel de pointer le le problème que
je viens d'évoquer à savoir de pointer
l'inanité de la dénonciation d'un
déficit d'un milliard d'euros et ce
raisonnement comme vous l'avez dit a
fait l'objet d'un chiffrage si on
supprimait les annexes 8 et 10 on ne
ferait pas 1 milliard d'euros d'économie
mais 320 millions
d'euros alors c cette mesure doit doit
être euh un petit peu discutée savoir ce
qu'on entend par euh 320 millions 20
millions d'euros et surtout qu'est ce
qu'on en induit comme comme but
politique et c'est là où il y a un
aspect qui me semble plus contestable
c'est-à-dire que le rapport de de
jean-patric Gill semble induire de ce
chiffrage un objectif de 320 millions
d'économie à réaliser alors pourquoi ce
raisonnement me paraît
contestable alors d'abord remarquons que
320 millions c'est un effort
considérable qui est demandé aux
intermittents et qui est d'un niveau
équivalent à celui qui avait été affiché
par la réforme de
2003 deuxièmement ce chiffrage demeure
un petit peu fragile parce qu'on ne sait
pas encore quels seront les dispositions
de du régime général qui sera adopté
l'année prochaine donc évidemment tout
ça peut être très variable ce chiffrage
peut exploser très très
facilement mais surtout c'est le
raisonnement qui qui me pose problème
dire aux intermittents si on vous
appliquait des dispositions inadaptées à
votre régime d'emploi celle du régime
général nous ferions 320 millions
d'économie donc il faut faire 320
millions d'économies sur les annexes 8
et 10 ça me paraît quelque chose de
difficilement audible par les
intermittents cela revient à dire nous
ne supprimons pas les annexes 8 et 10
mais nous les vidons à tel point de leur
substance qu'il vous sera indifférent de
de rester aux annexes 8 et 10 plutôt que
d'aller au régime
général et pour conclure ça me paraît
contradictoire disons avec l'idée même
de promouvoir une Flexi sécurité pour
les salariés flexible si on dit au
salariés flexibles que leur niveau de
sécurisation par rapport au chômage doit
se limiter à ce dont bénéficient ceux
qui ont par ailleurs une grande sécurité
de l'emploi on leur propose simplement
la
flexibilité de la flexibilité en plus
mais pas de de sécurité en plus donc il
me semble donc que le surcût ce qui a
été appelé le surcût de 320 millions des
ann 8 et 10 correspond exactement
correspond simplement à deux choses
d'une part au fait qu'il a une
inadaptation du régime général à un
emploi flexible et d'autre part à
l'objectif de Flexi sécurité je vous
remerci merci de cet autre regard et de
cette autre façon de considérer les
chiffres nous allons maintenant entendre
deux deux expertises d'usage en quelque
sorte du côté des entreprise du
spectacle vivant de la musique de
l'audiovisuel et du cinéma avec la
Fédération fésac en écoutant son
président puis du côté de ceux qui sont
quelquefois sur les planches la
coordination des intermittents et
précaire Monsieur Jacques peskin
président de la
fésac merci madame la
Présidente on a entendu beaucoup de
choses intéressantes beaucoup de comment
dire de prédisposés idéologiques aussi
dans les interventions moi ce que je
crois et vous l'avez d'ailleurs un peu
laissé entendre en introduction tout à
l'heure c'est que on a de nouveau
aujourd'hui tendance analyser la
question de de l'assurance chômage et
intermittent du spectacle en tant que
tel avant même de la replacer dans ce
qui est son son fond de tableau si je
veux dire c'est-à-dire l'emploi dans le
spectacle je voudrais rappeler quelques
très rapidement quelques éléments à ce
sujet éléments qui sont systématiquement
d'ailleurs occulé quand on parle de la
question et qui sont les suivants
d'abord le spectacle en général et je
rappelle que la Fédération que je
préside qui regroupe 32 organisations
professionnelles représentent à peu près
60 % directement de l'emploi dans le
spectacle donc je je pense pouvoir
parler en connaissance de cause le
spectacle en général est un secteur qui
double s emploi tous les 10 tous les 20
ans depuis 60 ans donc c'est un secteur
qui a créé énormément d'emploi au cours
des 60 dernières années certes il a créé
de l'emploi précaire on va y revenir
tout à l'heure mais pas seulement pas
seulement plus près de 60 % de la masse
salariale versé dans le spectacle et
c'est d'ailleurs pas il y a pas de quoi
s'en féliciter c'est simplement un fait
et versé à les salariés permanents qui
ont d'ailleurs des statut très différent
parce qu'il y a des tas de situations
différentes mais c'est très important de
le de le savoir il y a donc encore une
fois il y a à peu près 4 milliards de de
basse salarial dans le spectacle 1,8
chez les intermittents et à peu près 2,3
chez les salariés permanents donc c'est
une première chose et je crois qu'il
faut vraiment l'avoir à l'esprit le
spectacle est un secteur qui croit qui
embauche et j'insiste aussi sur ce point
dans c'est un secteur dans lequel il y a
beaucoup d'entrants et quels secteurs
aujourd'hui de l'économie française
peuvent se vanter d'accueillir du monde
alors certes c'est ces ces entrants le
fait que ces entrants soient nombreux
est lié à la précarité naturellement
puisque la précarité fait qu'il y a des
sortants et donc il y a des entrants
mais c'est quand même un élément très
important pour rappeler que le secteur
du spectacle dans son ensemble sert
aussi de porte d'entrée faire l'activité
à beaucoup de monde on nous reproche
parfois par exemple un dispositif trop
on nous reproche parce qu'on le reproche
aussi bien aux employeurs qu'au salariés
on l'a entendu tout à l'heure un
dispositif trop généreux dans
l'indemnisation mais ce dispositif je
j'insiste là-dessus permet à des entré
des entrées en activité qui autrement
serait probablement beaucoup plus
difficile à réaliser
alors autre élément très important je
crois c'est on on confond si jeose dire
ça revient ça reproche de ce que je
disais à l'instant sur les masses
salariales on confond intermittent ces
spectacles et on oublie le fondement de
la ce qu'on appelle intermittence ce qui
fait que dans le spectacle on a droit
nous les employeurs à recourir au
contrat à duré déterminé d'usage c'est
que nous travaillons et c'est vraiment
il faut comprendre c'est inhérant à la
nature même de l'activité de spectacle
nous travaillons par projet chaque
projet que ce soit un disque un
spectacle théâtral musical une émission
de télévision un film chaque projet est
un projet c'est un prototype qui il
n'est comparable à aucun autre ou à très
peu d'autres et il a besoin d'une équipe
non seulement dans sa composition
technique mais dans sa composition
individuelle d'une équipe particuli
alors c'est évident parce qu'on le
comprend tout de suite dans le cas des
artistes mais c'est vrai aussi dans le
cas de beaucoup de techniciens on
comprend tout de suite qu'un réalisateur
donné ne peut pas se voir imposer son
directeur photo son chefopérateur dans
le casre du cinéma par exemple ce
caractère
extraordinairement individuel de la
constitution des équipes de projets est
fondamental dans l'activité de spectacle
et c'est lui qui légitime le recours au
contrat d'usage je crois qu'on ne peut
pas traiter cette question sans y
revenir j'ajoute que contrairement à ce
qu'on laisse aussi entendre ce recours
au contrat d'usage varie énormément
selon les différentes branches du
spectacle en gros il est supérieur à 90
% dans la production cinématographique
je parle là en terme de masse salariale
alors qu'il est inférieur à % dans la
télédiffusion donc c'est pas le taux de
recours au contrat d'usage n'est pas en
soi si on considère le spectacle dans
son ensemble un critère opératoire il il
pourrait à la rigueur être opératoire à
l'intérieur d'une branche restreinte
mais certainement pas sur le spectacle
dans d'ensemble puisque en parlant de
taux de recours on mélange des gens dont
l'activité est en fait très différente
et pourquoi est-ce qu'elle est très
différente parce que cette notion
d'activité par projet n'a évidemment pas
le même sens dans le cas d'une chaîne de
télévision ou d'une radio par exemple ou
dans le cas d'une entreprise de
production cinématographique pour qui
chaque film est complètement séparé des
autres en général et pour pour qui il
n'existe pas de base sauf pour une
petite équipe technique technique
administrative qui existe de base pour
l'emploi permanent donc ça c'est tous
ces éléments là je pense qu'il faut les
rappeler systématiquement pour qu'on
comprenne dans quel contexte économique
et professionnel s'inscrit la question
que nous abordons aujourd'hui autre
élément qui est très important les
intermittents du spectacle c'est un mot
qui recrouve deux choses très
différentes c'est soit les salariés
employés sous contrat d'usage dans le
spectacle et je rappelle qu'il y en a
200 65000 chaque année soit les salariés
qui bénéficient de l'indemnisation de
l'annexe 8 ou de l'annexe 10 de
l'assurance chômage et a on sait qu'il y
en a entre 155000 et 110000 c'est donc
pas du tout pareil les 265000 personnes
que j'évoque évoqué à l'instant sont des
personnes qui cotisent dans les régimes
sociaux des intermittent et notamment à
l'assurance chômage bien sûr mais pas
seulement parce qu'il y a d'autres
régimes soci intermittents il faut le
rappeler une assurance maladie la
prévoyance la médecine du travail la
formation tous ces régimes sont des
régimes spécifiques qui ont été mis en
place pour eux et donc il y a 265 5000
personnes qui contribuent à l'équilibre
de ces régimes ou au déséquilibre dans
le cas qui occupe davantage aujourd'hui
et alors qu'une partie seulement et
c'est vrai de tous les dispositifs par
exemple en matière de formation il faut
pour avoir le droit à une formation
financée par le dispositif faire état
d'un certain volume d'activité qui n'est
pas le même d'ailleurs que celui du
chômage et par conséquent il y a bien un
mécanisme de sélection des a enroit par
rapport au contributeurs comme
d'ailleurs dans beaucoup de régimes
sociaux mais le mécanisme existe aussi
dans le cas des intermittant je vais
essayer d'aller vite parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de chos à dire mais j'insiste
beaucoup là-dessus parce que on ne peut
pas traiter spécifiquement la question
de l'assurance chômage sans la replacer
dans ce cadre de fonctionnement général
du du monde du
spectacle deuxème étape alors celle a é
davantage abordée elle sera certainement
par les ceux qui parleront après moi
c'est si j'ose dire le point de vue des
professionnels du spectacle eu même des
salariés alors là-dessus cela a été dit
je voudrais le répéter ici pour les
artistes en tout cas ça a été dit dans
le film d'introduction et je crois qu'on
ne répète pas assez contrairement à ce
qu'on croit quand on parle des fameux
s7ur c'est difficile d'atteindre les
seuils de l'assurance chômage c'est une
réalité qu'on doit dire les employeurs
sont parfaitement conscients de ça c'est
difficile à la fois parce que les
contrats sont souvent très courts qui
sont répartis entre entre des employeurs
très différents des secteurs d'activité
différents qu'il faut les il faut les
collecter ces contrats et c'est
difficile aussi parce que la matière la
manière même dont les contrats sont
passés et là certainement il y a des des
évolutions qui sont possibles dans les
rapports sociaux les rend encore plus
court que ça pourrait dans quelque fois
être le cas donc ça c'est une réalité et
je crois que en ce qui nous concerne
nous disons très clairement et nous
voulons le dire la la plus grande
fermeté il n'est pas envisageable pour
nous de durcir les conditions d'accès
des artistes à l'indemnisation parce que
c'est aujourd'hui ce sont aujourd'hui
des conditions qui sont difficiles en
revanche le cas des technicien ça a été
dit tout à l'heure d'ailleurs peut faire
l'objet de discussion on n pas
aujourd'hui de propositions à faire sur
ce point mais n nous pensons que la
différenciation qui a été très
modestement d'ailleurs mise en œuvre en
20032006 n'est pas illégitime et on peut
pe peut-être aller plus loin d'ailleur
je suis un peu surpris de ce qu'a dit le
représentant de LAF le représentant qu'a
dit Monsieur de Virville tout à l'heure
à propos de des gens qui s'arrêteraient
dès qu'ils ont le seuil parce qu'on a
quand même près de 50 % des techniciens
qui ont plus de 680 he un techniciens
indemnisés qui ont plus de 680 heur de
travail donc c'est bien qu'ils se sont
pas arrêtés le jour où ils ont eu 507ur
donc c'est
c'est nous on peut dire qu'il y a des
éléments de différenciation avec des
complexités parce que dans certaines
catégories professionnelles qui sont
aujourd'hui des techniciens les mur
enciène ou les réalisateurs par exemple
leur mode d'emploi se rapproche parfois
davantage de celui des artistes donc il
faudrait peut-être affiner le
raisonnement mais globalement cette
différenciation n'est pas
illégitime alors j'insiste aussi je l'ai
dit rapidement tout à l'heure mais il
faut pas l'oublier que le fait que les
les intermittants du spectacle dispose
de d'un dispositif de d'assurance
chômage particulier n'est pas le seul
d'une manière générale dans le domaine
du spectacle et pour la raison que
j'aiévoqué tout à l'heure la
flexibilité est une réalité et par
conséquent la flexisécurité est une
nécessité c'est pas par hasard qu'on a
dès les années 70 mis en place un
système de formation continue dont les
intermittents peuvent bénéficier entre
les contrats et pas pendant les contrats
la notion de portabilité de la
protection sociale qui s'applique
d'ailleurs aussi à la complémentaire
maladie c'est une notion qui est
absolument indispensable dans le casre
des intermittents c'est facile à
comprendre et qui a effectivement été
mise en œuvre par les partenaires
sociaux alors le troisème morceau qui
est celui qu'on aborde naturellement qui
est bien sûr un enjeu qui qui est celui
que vous voulez qu'on traite mais je
pensais qu'on pouvait pas y aller trop
vite c'est la question ce qu'on peut
appeler l'intensité de la solidarité les
intermittant doivent ce sont des
salariés naturellement ça a été ça a été
répété ils doivent être intégrés dans
les dans les différents mécanismes de
solidarité internationale
interprofessionnel pardon rappelons
d'ailleurs que en matière de retraite
par exemple les intermittents sont des
contributeurs nets évidemment parce
qu'ils sont globalement assez jeunes et
par conséquent ils contribuent au régime
de retraite de même qu'il contribuent au
régime de de base de l'assurance maladie
mais ça il y a pas de quoi s'inventer ça
résulte d'éléments démographiques donc
c'est c'est c'est un
élément enfin ce sont ce que je veux
dire c'est que ça s'inscrit dans une
dans un dispositif général de protection
sociale mais bien sûr le cas de
l'assurance chômage est très visible
puisque on a des dispositifs
particuliers qui entre parenthèses sont
indispensables d'abord pour des raisons
techniques parce que techniquement la
situation des intermittents est
différent de celle des autres contrats
précaires et la gestion de leur
situation même si on les par hypothèse
on les rapatrier dans l'annexe 4 ou dans
une annexe comparable serait très
complexe pour le pour pô emploi parce
que dans les fêes il y a énormément de
contrat d'un ou deux jours qui pour
lesquels les dispositifs ne sont pas
bien appliqués pas pas bien adaptés donc
il y a de toute façon besoin de
dispositifs particulierers mais ça
n'empêche pas et là je crois qu'il faut
pas le refuser du tout ça n'empêche pas
de se poser la question de l'intensité
de la solidarité et à cet égard je dois
dire que le raisonnement qu'a fait
monsieur dev tout à l'heure nous paraît
raisonnable ça nous paraît raisonnable
de s'intéresser au ratio prestation sur
cotisation et
d'examiner s'il est possible même sans
se donner ment un objectif
extraordinaire d'examiner s'il est
légitime qu'il soit à ce point supérieur
à celui des autres dispositifs précaires
bien sûr puisque c'est ça et ça c'est
bien que ce soit aujourd'hui reconnu
comme tel c'est ça le point de
comparaison et si il y a des
dispositions qu'on peut mettre en œuvre
pour pour les en rapprocher ce que je
voulais dire en conclusion à ce stade et
son je deux ou trois mots précis après
c'est que en ce qui nous concerne les
employeuxs organisés du spectacle nous
sommes pas du tout fermés à cette
réflexion aussi bien d'ailleurs du côté
des recettes que du côté des dépenses et
nous pensons elle est légitime que dans
une période où l'ensemble des
des parties de la société l'ensemble des
groupes de la société sont euh amenés à
s'interroger sur les dispositifs de
protection sociale et sur leur
financement il est évidemment légitime
que ce soit le cas aussi du régime des
intermittents du spectacle et en aucune
manière n nous nous pensons que ça ne
serait pas légitime néanmoins nous le
redisons il y a des des des des points
durs auxquels il nous paraît absolument
impossible de toucher alors je voulais
insister sur deux ou trois points sur
l'utau de recours j'en ai dit un mot
tout à l'heure c'est un concept qui n'a
pas beaucoup de sens si on le considère
je le redis parce que c'est important
sur le dans le spectacle dans son
ensemble parce qu'il varie énormément d'
d'une branche à l'autre et même au sein
des branches parce que dans même dans le
spectacle subventionné par exemple vous
avez à la fois des centres dramatiques
qui ont des emplois permanent en
quantité importantes et qui ont donc un
taux de recours qui peut-être de l'ordre
de 30 40 % et des compagnies pour lequel
le taux de recours sera beaucoup plus
élevé alors même que ces deux types de
d'entités appartiennent à la même
branche du spectacle vivant subventionné
je craint que le concept de taux de
recours soit une fausse bonne idée même
si on comprend sa sa justification et
qu'elle conduise à des aberrations
totales l'autre sujet qu'on met
régulièrement sur la table c'est celui
de la permittence et là aussi je pense
qu'il faut faire attention à ce qu'on
dit d'abord sur un point purement
technique si par permittant on entend
quelqu'un qui travaille 9 mois et qui
est qui est indemnisé par l'assurance
chômage 3 mois ce qu'on entend parfois
dire il est probablement vrai qu'une
partie importante de ces personnes
devrait être re transformé en CDI mais
il n est pas moins vrai que ces
personnes ne pèsent pas sur le
l'assurance chômage au contraire ce sont
évidemment des contributeurs à
l'assurance chômage puisquil il cotise
pendant 9 mois ce qui est évidemment
beaucoup plus que la grande majorité des
bénéficiaires de l'assurance chômage
donc là-dessus je crois qu'il faut pas
se tromper d'objectif c'est pour des
raisons c'est pour des raisons de
principe que nous partageons tout à fait
d'ailleurs qu'il faut limiter le recours
abusif au contrat d'usage mais il faut
pas croire que cette limitation aura des
effets décisifs sur l'équilibre lui-même
c'est encore une fois je ne vous mprenez
pas je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas le
faire je dis faut pas tromper sur ses
effets réels alors sur la sur la
permittance je suis un peu surpris
d'ailleurs dans vos propositions cette
notion de différencier la permittance
subie et la permittance voulue la
permittance elle est qu'elle soit subie
ou voulue la question c'est de savoir si
c'est légitime que
l'interprofession comment dire indemnise
des personnes qui pourraent ne pas
l'être bon c'est ça il me semble que
c'est ça la question qui est posée et
cette question est posée qu'elle soit
subie ou voulu dans les deux cas elle
elle si c'est pas bien c'est pas bien si
c'est si c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
donc je crois pas que cette
différenciation est est de sens en
revanche il faut bien avoir conscience
que il faut pas se tirer des balles dans
le pied
si on dit je dis je dis pas n'importe
quoi parce que c'est un exemple qu'on C
souvent si on dit à telle région de
France 3 qu'il ne qu'elle ne doit pas
recourir à des chefs moteurs en
intermittence elle va pas employer des
chefsmteurs en permanent elle va
renoncer à faire du montage donc c'est
le résultat sera pas nécessairement un
résultatage à cet endroit-là elle
regroupera son montage
moins de de disposition géographique et
le chef monteur en question qui avait la
chance d'habiter à limoge ou dans une
dans une région moins dense il aura
perdu son employeur encore une fois je
ne dis pas qu'il ne faut rien faire
c'est pas du tout ça l'idée ce que nous
disons sur la permittance c'est qu'il
appartient au branche du spectacle et au
partenaires sociaux de chacune des
branches du spectacle de poursuivre le
travail qui a été mené d'ailleurs avec
beaucoup de précision dans la dans
depuis 2005 consistant à limiter les
conditions de recours au contrat d'usage
ça ça une démarche parfaitement légitime
qu'il faut poursuivre mais la poursuivre
de manière trop générale nous paraît une
mauvaise idée voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire
merci je vous propose d'entendre deux
participants qui ont choisi la parité
pour s'exprimer ça ne double pas votre
temps vous avez la parole et bien
Véronique va parler plus que moi je veux
justeah rappeler puisque madame la
Présidente d'ailleurs je vous remercie
de nous avoir invité que nous avons
relancé un comité de suivi qu'on appelle
comité de suivi 2013 les organisations
associatives professionnelles euh
concerné par l'intermittence se sont
rassemblé en assemblée générale le 17
juin au Théâtre de la Colline et que
nous commençons à contacter des
parlementaires dont deux sont sont
présents ici Pierre Laurent et André
catolin qui donc ont accepter de
rejoindre ce comité de suivi et il y a
également Noël Mamère historique André
chassigne et nous continuons euh de
chercher à en contacter dans l'idée
d'avoir des parlementaires de tout bord
dans le but de faire une réunion
prochaine avant les
négociations voilà pour cette
information ensuite bon beaucoup de
choses ont été dites auxquelles il est
difficile de pas réagir et c'était pas
le but de de mon intervention mais euh
première chose par rapport à à ce qu'a
dit Monsieur Destival c'est exactement
ce qu'on a constaté et qu'on a
d'ailleurs dénoncé dans une des
premières enfin dénoncé en tout cas mis
en en question ce débat euh dans la
première étude que nous avions mené la
coordination financée par quatre régions
à l'époque à savoir la bascule
progressive euh du système de
l'assurance chômage des intermittents
dans un système de plus en plus
assurentiel on avait fait un coefficient
de corrélation dans le protocole
précédent 2003 on avait euh un système
qui était euh également redistributif
euh que également assurentiel
c'est-à-dire euh il respecter le du du
niveau de de salaire comment il le
reportait dans le système de 2003 ce
qu'on a tous constaté c'est que les
gens les intermittents ont vu leur
allocation augmenter de 20 à 30 % ça a
été corrigé en 2007 parce que la Cour
des comptes avait elle-même dénoncé que
c'était quand même étonnant d'avoir fait
une réforme qui était censée coûter
moins cher mais qui avait coûté plus
cher au final mais le prix à payer de
cette réforme a été celui humain des
gens qui ont été précarisés pas
forcément sortis immédiatement du mais
ça veut dire pour rester batailler
encore plus et ça je vais le redire
artiste comme technicien c'està dire
quand on n pas sorti c'est une
précarisation à l'intérieur de la
profession qui s'est faite c'est-à-dire
que les contrats se sont morcelés
c'estàdire que les salaires ont baissé
et donc depuis 2003 même si comme vous
le dites monsieur Peskine l'industrie
culturelle se porte bien par contre tout
ce qui on qui concerne beaucoup
l'intermittence à
savoir tout ce qui pourrait être du
travail plus indépendant des des
productions plus indépendantes du
spectacle vivant du théâtre de création
lui il se porte beaucoup moins bien il
est en stagnation voire en régression et
que donc dans ce contexte économique
toute réforme qui viserait à durcir les
conditions d'entrée dans le régime
serait une totale catastrophe serait
absolument pas accepté par les
intermittents qu'il soi artistes ou
techncien ça aurait le mérite de
relancer le mouvement remarquez mais euh
sur les techniciens je trouve
contradictoire ce que vous avez dit
Monsieur beskin quand vous dites à quel
point nous sommes dans une économie par
projet les techniciens avec lesquels
nous travaillons sont dans le même
projet et ce qui définit l'intermittant
du spectacle c'est la discontinuité de
l'emploi ce n'est pas un statut
d'artiste comme nous l'avons répété même
s'il est plus plus plus difficile pour
les artistes de l'obtenir s'il y a des
techniciens qui se portent mieux que
d'autres et bien tant mieux ces
techniciens ctisent mais il y a 10 à 20
% de techniciens d'après les les données
dques qui tourn autour des 507urs et
pourquoi ça serait donc c'est plus
fragile de ces techniciens qui devrai
payer parce qu'il y en a qui le sont
moins c'est un raisonnement que j'ai du
mal à comprendre il y a des gens qui
bossent bien donc ceux qui bossent moins
bien devrai dégager donc nous nous
opposons farouement à tout durcissement
des conditions d'entrée et la séparation
artistes technicien n'a pas d'autre but
de toute façon d' terme de basculer des
techniciens dans le régime de l'intérim
c'est sont des but affiché depuis des
années par le patronat bizarrement
repris par les arguments de la Cour des
comptes il n'a pas d'autre raison il n'y
a pas de raison comptable de séparer les
artistes et techniciens et
historiquement
l'intermittence c'était cinéma d'un côté
parce que c'était pas tout à fait la
même économie et théâtre spectacle
vivant d'un côté voilà cette séparation
arti ntien n'a n'a aucun sens pour nous
donc c'est pour ça que nous avons lu les
les propositions de de de votre mission
qui pour la plupart sont très
intéressantes notamment sur la la
question du plafond de cumul mais
évidemment vous vous vous doutez bien
que la proposition 5 n'est pas un
problème de tabou c'est pas un tabou
c'est juste mettre si on parle 20 % de
de techniciens à la rue c'est pas un
problème de tabou c'est juste précariser
encore plus la profession qu'elle ne
l'est et enfin je conclurai là-dessus la
question du pollueur payeur alors là
vraiment il faut débattre de ça parce
que comme vous l'avez dit Monsieur
beskin les choses sont très différentes
il y a vraiment plein de de de de types
d'entreprises différentes et si on prend
le spectacle vivant 99 % des compagnies
de théâtrre n'emboue que les
intermittents donc si ces gens-là dont
par principe ils sont dans une économie
par projet ils devaient être pénalisés
parce qu'ils ne font que des CDD c'est
condamner à terme les compagnies de
théâtre on peut souhaiter qu'il y ait
plus de moyens pour que les compagnies
de théâtre puisse avoir plus de
permanent on est tous d'accord là-dessus
ce n'est pas le cas donc pourquoi
toujours vouloir réguler en voulant
précariser encore plus les gens nous
avons fait des propositions que vous
avez repris il y a des possibles mode de
régulation par le déplafonnement par le
plafond de cumule salaire indemnité
c'est-à-dire une mesure qui est
peut-être un peu de gauche que les gens
plus riches payent pour les plus pauvres
c'est peut-être pas trop d'actualité en
ce moment mais c'est ce que nous
défendons un truc assez simple et je
passe la parole à
Véronique oui donc Benon bonjour moi je
vais vous parler plutôt de l'angleue le
du point de vue du terrain de ce qui se
passe aussi au bout et qui pourrait
rejoindre ce qu'a dit Mathieu Grégoire
qui est que oui il y a des annexe 8 et
10 mais aussi l'art comment les vider
elles peuvent très bien exister teles
qu'elles sont là ou être modifié et
pourtant il se passe sur le terrain un
autre phénomène qui est qu'on les vide
qu'on exclut des intermittents jour
après jour par des
pratiques que je vais vous expliquer
pour rappel je nous avons créé des
permanences depuis 2000 d'accueil où
nous informons des petites structures
nous accueillons des intermittents qui
sont désespérés et nous essayons de
débloquer leur situation débloquer leur
dossier nous les accompagnons et cetera
c'est par ce biaislà qu'on s'est penché
sur la réglementation et cetera et de là
de cette position là ce qu'on a ce qu'on
réalise et de vraiment c'est que et les
structures et les intermittents en bout
de chaîne se retrouvent coincés entre
deux mâchoires ou deux points de
pression qui sont un la réglementation
bien sûr qui est en casre l'emploi
culturel qui est complexe très complexe
textes multiples qui sont remaniés il y
a des décret qui arrivve il y a des tas
de choses qui qui n'arrêtent pas de
bouger des petites choses qui sont
opaques il y a des choses qui se des
textes qui se contredisent don il y a
d'un seul coup on va comment dire
interpréter ces textes et il y a aussi
surtout une grande inadaptation à nos
pratiques qui évolue toujours et encore
il se passe beaucoup de choses par
exemple l'artiste et le technicien
actuellement ne sont plus que ne sont
pas que sur des plateaux ils
interviennent en centres sociaux en
prison pourquoi parce que ils en ont
aussi le désir mais aussi parce que au
niveau du territoire on leur demande
d'aller là on leur demande mais la
réglementation qui est en place n'est
pas adapté spécifiquement ou les exclus
du fait qu'il pratique cela je le je je
le prouverai tout à l'heure par des
petits exemples j'esserai donc ça c'est
imp les pratiques de polyactivité on se
retrouve actuellement ça a évolué on se
retrouve des fois sur des postes
hybrides on peut avoir deux fonctions en
étant comédien monter le enfin c'est
c'est la réalité des petites compagnies
c'est la de là pareil on pourrait être
exclu avoir un redressement pour
l'employeur et une une un refus
d'ouverture de droit pour l'employé on
se retrouve aussi sur des des projets
artistiques qui croisent différentes
pratiques c'est l'évolution c'est
l'évolution la vidéo la danse le théâtre
le le cinéma tout ça se croise
maintenant sauf que dans la
réglementation on ne peut pas euh si on
n pas le bon code APE mais comment
dire il faut que la fonction corresponde
au bon code APE qui est déterminé par
rapport à l'activité principale de de
l'entreprise ou l'association et cetera
et donc si on se retrouve avec une
fonction qui n'est pas dans ce cadre là
comment fait-on re les heures ne sont
pas prises en compte donc ça je cite et
ça continue d'évoluer nos pratiques
évolue tous les jours et c'est superbe
sauf que ça suit pas derrière alors les
pratiques de gestion collec on est aussi
voilà ce sont des projets ce sont c'est
ensemble les projets se montent ensemble
et dans la gestion et sur et dans la
réalisation et ça aussi on se retrouve
lors des contrôles contrôle mandataire
et cetera face à des choses mais assez
incroyables et on pourrait aussi parler
des pratiques de création je vous cite
donc tous ces points là qui que je vous
donnerai des petits exemples et du coup
avec tout ce croisement de texte et
cetera et en plus les conséquences de du
protoc des du protocole qui est passé il
est quasi mais impossible faut être
expert en la matière pour arriver à
rentrer dans les bonnes cases pour être
dans le dans dans le le droit et à si à
cela on ajoute la deuxième machoire qui
est et je regrette que enfin pôul emploi
ne soit pas présent parce que nous c'est
notre voilà du coup je vais m'axer
là-dessus c'est la dérive des pratiques
de Pôle Emploi dérive des pratiques de
Pole Emploi et là c'est de la colère
parce que là c'est la vraie
précarisation c'est vraiment les gens
qui sortent du système qui n'ont plus
rien ils passent du RSA à rien du tout
faut être bien clair et là c'est quoi
donc c'est contrôle avec des pratiques
insidieuses et interprétation des
textes complètement surréaliste avec le
guuso aussi le guuso on pourrait en
reparler parce que là ils sont encore à
part on ne sait pas pourquoi mais à
part
alors nous on part du principe que Paul
emploi considère on a l'impression et on
en est quasi sûr que un ayant droit est
potentiellement un fraudeur voilà déjà
le le le principe de base donc il
va il va contrôler contrôler par
différents systèmes et ce qui fait que
de l'autre côté dans la pratique de nos
emplois il y a la peur du contrôle du
coup il y a un glissement de nos droits
qui commence à se
faire un glissement de nos pratiques de
la pour faire en plus avec la volonté la
volonté de bien faire donc là aussi N
droit se restregne par ce biais-là du
coup du coup la voie du contrôle qui a
choisi depuis 2003 pour régeler notre
profession est catastrophique autant que
le protocole elle est insidieuse elle
touche toutes les professions qui se
mettent à adopter des pratiques d'emploi
plus restrictive et surtout dans le
contexte actuel des productions avec le
lot de restriction budgétaire les
contrôles qui fragilisent les plus
petites structures celles qui prennent
tous les risques de l'emploi et surtout
les intermittents qui sont en bout
dechaîne et qui sont les plus contrôlé
pour pour ces derniers l'accès au droit
actuellement est aléatoire voilà donc
pour mieux illustrer je vais vous donner
quelques petits exemples on va prendre
euh contrairement à ce que vous disiez
Monsieur David de Virville c'est que la
personne qui avait deux emplois n'était
pas hors elle est dans son droit aussi
et c'est ce qui se passe souvent sur le
terrain surtout actuellement je vais
prendre monsieur X comédien il a cumulé
deux emplois différents il a ses heures
d'intermittent
et il avait il a dit oui pour combler
ses fin de mois un petit boulot donc il
donnait à peu près 4 heures de cours de
langue dans une association et cetera
sur un contrat qui était l'ordre de 5
mois que se passe-t-il en bout de chane
il a ses
5ur Paul emploi actuellement va lui
ouvrir des droits au régime général car
il va Paul emploi va regarder le temps
d'affiliation d'un contrat de plus de
122 jours qui est là qui est présent
puisqu'il a dit oui à ce petit boulot en
plus alors qu'il a ses7 7h et là P
l'emploi n'applique pas la
réglementation dans sa totalité car
normalement il devrait lui être appliqué
la réglementation qui lui est la plus
favorable autre chose avec cette
réglementation qui est là un musicien
intermittent depuis longtemps voilà il
est intermittent et parallèlement à ça
comme le monsieur qui a témoigné tout à
l'heure il donne des cours dans un
conservatoire municipal il donne 8h de
cours il a fait un remplacement il a
donné pareil plus de il a eu un contrat
au-delà de 4 mois voilà il arrive en fin
de droit il a pas eu ses cachets chose
courante il les a pas mais il a plus de
128 heures de cours il a été mis en
place suite aux luttes que nous avons
mené quand même une enveloppe
gouvernementale enfin le gouvernement a
mis
l'APS laallocation de
professionnalisation de solidarité et la
FD la loocation de fin de droit pour
parer à ces choseslà qui est l'accident
de parcours et qui peut permettre dès
que l'intermittent retrouve ses heures à
réouvrir des droit en aureux annexe 8 et
10 il se passe que il y a eu un petit
texte une instruction numéro 2012 100 du
22 juin 2012 qui est passé donc pour
l'emploi donc c'est interne et qui fait
que ils vont d'abord regarder
l'ouverture de droit au régime général
avant de regarder s'il avait le droit à
laallocation de professionnalisation et
de solidarité donc ce monsieur se
retrouve avec une allocation réduite car
en plus le calcul va se faire que sur
les heur les les les les 8h travaillés
en conservatoire municipal déjà sur 122
jours les 5007ur qu'il les pas les 7ur
les 33 cachéss qu'il avait ne vont pas
être vont être avalés par puisqu'ils
sont dans son sa période de référence ne
vont plus compter et il lui restera 122
jours pour refaire 507 he pour pouvoir
réouvrir des droits il commence à sortir
du système hier il y a une personne à la
permanence qui est arrivé non mais c'est
l'hallucination excusez-moi mais il y a
des moments on a du mal à rester calme
elle est arrivée même car elle elle
avait pas ses 507 heur pas de souci
normalement elle avait droit à ouvrir la
clause de sauvegarde qui est 122 jours à
28 €. de même la Pôle Emploi instruction
interne je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé lui a ouvert des droits où elle a
elle touche
0,97 centimes voilà c'est son taux par
jour et parce qu'ils l' lui on vert des
droits au régime général et comme elle
faisait très peu d'heures et que le
calcul s'est fait sur ces heures et que
les heures d'Inter qu'elleavait non pas
compté elle se retrouve avec 0,97
centimes donc là dérive dérive dérive et
non application du droit laaps existe
lafd existe les choses existent nous
bataillons jour après jour je peux vous
dire qu'on on bat on met des des des des
des mois des fois des années pour
certains on arrive à à ce qu'il recouvre
leurs droit mais c'est de
l'acharnement euh un autre exemple alors
là c'est quand euh le dernier ah non
mais faudrait que je parle des contrôles
bon alors juste je vais citer vite fait
il y a aussi que Paul emploi et le guuso
se permettent d'estimer qu'est-ce qu' un
spectacle ou non on a vu une compagnie
de danse les heures de répétition parce
qu'il y avait écrit résidence de
création qui n'ont été basculé au régime
général imaginez d'un seul coup comme
c'était une création il ne pouvait pas
répéter puisque l'œuvre n'existait pas
on a vu euh des chanteuses lyriques
comme elle chantaient dans une église
qui ont été embauchés pour chanter faire
leur travail leur métier qui ont été
rebasculés par le guuso euh au régime
général pourquoi parce que le public qui
venait à la messe n'est pas un public
puisqu'il venait à la messe dérive
dérive dérive donc là je reviens sur
lesôs je vais faire très rapidement
he et la alors je voulais juste parler
de la pratique insidieuse des contrôles
mandataires les contrôles se font
contrôle mandataire c'est la recherche
la collusion entre employeurs employés
le système inidieux c'est que Paul
emploi va aller vers l'intermittent et
non pas vers l'employeur lui envoyer un
dossier de dirigeants qui et lui donne
15 jours pour remplir tout ça et lui
demander les statuts et cetera tous les
papiers de l'employeur lui voulant bien
faire sous la pression du temps alors
que ce n'est il y a pas de texte de loi
qui dit qu'il y a 15 jours pour fournir
ses papiers mais bon peu importe il va
tout faire pour le faire et si remplit
et qu'il arrive à quand même essayer de
se dépatouer il va être dirigeant de
fait et voilà et il tombe alors je vais
revenenir sur cette histoire de contrôle
depuis
2003 il y a des contrôles tous les
rapports le disent pas plus de % sont
avérés donc stop à l'acharnement stop et
la pratique de P emploi c'est un couper
les droits pourquoi couper les droits en
premier il faut que il soit avéré qu'il
y a fraude donc pourquoi couper les
droits de perception des indus sans
respecter le minimum vital sans
information je bon je vais passer parce
que il y en a beaucoup donc moi je vais
enevenenir aux conclusions qui est pour
nous de revenir un état de confiance il
y a des choses à faire très rapidement
qui peuvent être très rapides état de
confiance c'est un ok suspicion il y a
il y a a une suspicion pourquoi pas le
contrôle on ne coupe pas les droits tant
que la faute n'est pas avérée on fait un
contrôle amiable on échange les pièces
on demande à la bonne personne si c'est
l'employeur et cetera on offre à la
personne aux personnes contrôlées un
moyen de recours un moyen de recours à
Mo nous il y a pôul emploi en face en
face ils ont rien le médiateur de pôul
emploi qui lui-même dénonce la PR de P
emploi donc enfin pour vous dire c'est
une énorme usine à Gace qu'il faut
restructurer on est bien d'accord mais
pendant ce temps-là c'est des
intermittents qui trinquent tous les
jours tous les jours donc ne pas
interrompre les droits donner les moyens
de prévention et de recours P emploi
doit avoir l'obligation de justifier son
contrôle sur des motifs fondés en droit
et en fait il ne le fait quasi jamais
c'est nous qui le demandons
systématiquement stopper le harcèlement
administratif sinon on doit pouvoir
faire l'objet de recours immédiat euh
et aussi que s'il y a recours amayable
c'est qu'il y a le CNCS le CNCS c'est
qui c'est pa emploi donc d'avoir un
recours amiable je dirais
plus le mot indépendant voilà ce qui
voilà ce voilà donc bon j'ai fait j'ai
fait un petit peu court je voulais en
dire plus et de dire à Paul emploi de
revenir à sa mission courante qui est
quand même l'accueil même si bon vous
savez dans j'ai pas parlé de la
plateforme téléphonique des courriers
dématérialisés et cetera de revenir à
l'information c'est fondamental on ne
connaît pas nos droits on se retrouve
face à des montagnes à gravir et de
revenir à l'orientation et au versement
des allocations et non à la rupture des
allocations voilà je reviens juste et
après je vous jure j'arrête je suis ravi
que le la problématique du congé
maternité soit pris en compte sauf que
je voulais juste signaler que les arrêts
maladies c'est la même légis c'est
exactement la même réglementation qui
s'applique pour eux et je ne comprends
pas et il est urgent que tout ceci que
ce qui va être fait pour les
mattermitant s'applique aussi pour les
arrêts maladies ce sont les mêmes
calculs mêmes problèmes et quand on est
malade et qu'on a rien au bout c'est
pareil voilà merci
oui c'est ça c'est exactement je voulais
rappeler concernant les matières
mitantes que cet amendement est passé
dans le cadre de la loi sur l'égalité
homme femme donc pas de maladie possible
et cetera voilà mais il faut
le cadre de la loi et c'était égalité
hommes-femme et là il y avait une
rupture d'égalité de traitement entre
les hommes discrimination entre les
hommes intermittents et les femmes en
situation de il y a il y a
discrimination entre c'est du fait de la
CPAM aussi entre le le droit commun et
et nos pratiques à nous qui sont pas
adaptés je le dis il faudrait se se
pencher là-dessus et justement on
demande au gouvernement de pouvoir
flécher ça
se pcher làus déjà c'est déjà un
consensus qui a été créé sur cet
amendement assez
exceptionnel grâce au courage de Blondin
vous avez raison de signaler que
d'autres sujets restent tout si chaud et
quand je dis le fléchage c'est aussi
pour P emploi c'est fondamental il y a
moyen de faire des choses rapidement on
est on a le double contrôle je le
signale Laem tous les ans non mais c'est
important on est les seuls le seul c'est
avoir le double contrôle l'employeur
envoie l'EM à Pemploi l'employé a une
AEM comment se fait-il quand l'employé
oublie par omission de pointer mais
comment se fait-il que Paul emploi ne
lui dise pas vous avez dû omettre on l'a
la preuve que vous avez travaillé alors
qu'après il va à son ouverture de droit
lui dire vos heures sont pas prises en
compte vous devez des indus non mais
votre expertise d'usage est précieuse
mais ne croyez pas que les
parlementaires connaissent mal le sujet
parce que je vous l'ai dit nous sommes
destinataires de multiples dossiers
individuels très précis et nous mesurons
la disparité géographique des
traitements également règle ici non
règle
ailleur nous avons 20 minutes chers
collègu là si vous avez des questions à
poser sur ce champ-l enjeu du régime
expertise témoignage parce qu'après on
parle des mesures d'accompagnement et
après nous entendrons les négociations
enfin les partenaires sociaux qui seront
associés à la négociation avez-vous des
questions alors madame Gontier
main merci madame la
Présidente moi je crois que la
Commission a eu raison d'investir cette
question même si on déjà on sait déjà
beaucoup de choses puisque effectivement
nous sommes
régulièrement interpellé euh moi je
trouve que il y a un véritable enjeu
effectivement sur le diagnostic et sur
notre capacité à avoir un diagnostic
partagé parce que je suis un peu sur ma
fin si vous voulez parce que j'aurais
aimé qu'on puisse susciter d'autres
réactions y compris de partenaires qui
vont intervenir plus tard parce que il
faut quand même qu'on se construise
notre réflexion euh de façon correcte
voilà je veux revenir au petit film
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure alors
l'intermittence n'est pas un statut
c'est c'est un ensemble de règles nous
l'avons dit en même temps j'ai été très
très interpellé parce que j'ai entendu
c'est-à-dire que j'ai a entendu une
aspiration à de la sécurisation à de la
sécurité face à ce qui a été démontré
par un nombre d'entre vous sur la
discontinuité de l'emploi et je me
demande justement si une des questions
que nous n'avons pas à investir c'est
cette question de de justement de la
structure dans l'emploi dans dans ces
métiers euh euh parce que si vous voulez
derrière ces hommes et ces femmes il y a
de la vie il y a de la souffrance et ça
a été très bien dit par nombre nombre
d'entre vous notamment vous madame euh
il y a au quotidien c'est la difficulté
c'est la difficulté de trouver un
contrat c'est la difficulté d'en avoir
plusieurs pour totaliser ces heures
c'est la difficulté même de
concrétisation Duat du contrat avec
quelquefois des contrats qui se
réalisent à postériori du travail
effectué donc voilà tout ça pour dire
quoi c'est que je crois qu'il ne serait
pas raisonnable de penser pouvoir passer
au-delà des 507 heur et je m je pense
même que la question qui a été pointée
qu'elle puisse s'effectuer sur 12 mois
et non pas sur 10 mois me paraît quand
même être une piste à regarder de près
je dis ça pourquoi parce que on voit
bien que nous sommes dans une période de
de contrainte budgétaire avec des
budgets qui se qui se resserrent
évidemment avec des des donc des des
conséquences y compris sur l'emploi
encore une fois donc je je veux dire mon
inquiétude de de de ce de ce côté-là je
suis très très intéressée parce que vous
avez dit sur la question des femmes je
je je soutiens vraiment le travail de
marieivonne Blondin qui nous a alerté
parce que effaré par les conditions qui
étaient faites aux femmes en situation
de congé maternité mais pour être
présidente de la délégation au droits
des femmes on a pu montrer que dans le
secteur de la culture les femmes
n'étaient pas n'échappaient pas aux
catastrophes aux catastrophes dont elles
étaient victimes ailleurs c'est-à-dire
la perdurance de de de stéréotypes euh
la discontinuité de de de de de carrière
l'invisibilité des créatrices et cetera
donc j'aurais aimé savoir si quelqu'un
pouvait davantage me renseigner mais
peut-être qu'on va avancer aussi dans la
dans la dans l'articulation des trois
des trois tables des trois TBL ronde sur
des éléments d'appréciation de du point
de vue des femme intermittente parce que
j'imagine que ça doit être encore plus
la galère euh que dans une situation où
on est en emploi stable sans souci pour
pour le lendemain lorsque on avance la
question de raccourcir le congé parental
pour permettre d'asseoir davantage la la
coresponsabilité des parents j'imagine
que quand on est en
intermittence voyez ça doit sûrement pas
se poser comme ça non plus donc voilà
j'aurais été intéressée par des éléments
de de ce point de
vue-là merci Monsieur le scouarnc
oui madame la Présidente c'est le
scouarnc juste petit observation d'abord
je crois que il y a eu beaucoup de
chiffres de données sur le déficit mais
il a été donné aussi par Monsieur pesk
notamment ilid qu'il y avait un apport
considérable de l'intermittence donc à
la culture pour notre pays et un apport
donc pour notre population qui en a bien
besoin même en temps de crise et
peut-être surtout par temps de crise
donc il faut d'abord noter un apport
considérable et par conséquent le
déficit qui n'a pas qui n'a pas qui n'a
pas accru depuis une dizaine d'années
quand même donc c'est stabilisé la
flexis sécurité ça me semble
indispensable également pour la
profession par ailleurs j'ai bien
entendu des critiques par rapport à Pô
emploi et j'avais justement une
question je me demande si les agents de
Pôle emploi peuvent avoir du mal à
maîtriser les les difficultés des de la
la profession il me semble qu'il y a
beaucoup de spécificités donc peut-être
que il serait utile d'avoir une
formation il spécifique
pour pour
aider par ailleurs la permittance alors
sur la permittance est-ce qu'il y a
abus et ça ça peut être réglé ça il me
semblerait que les abus ça peut ça peut
se régler par rapport donc aux
télévisions en particulier qui
emploierait de manière permanente tout
en déclarant des intermittents donc ça
me paraît un
peu le secteur qu'il faudra regarder de
plus près pour que ce soit
juste si on est tous attaché à la notion
de justice il faut pas qu'il a de triche
donc vérifier j'ai des doutes puisque
j'ai rencontré un intermittent qui m'a
dit qu'il avait des doutes sur cette
question merci merci Monsieur le
scouarn c'est très dur monsieur
gatelin merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais revenir un peu dans la lignée
des interventions prédente sur plusieurs
choses je suis un peu étonné par je
crois que c'est Monsieur de Virville qui
a
évoqué le seuil de 507 he et le qui et
le fait qu'il y avait beaucoup de gens
qui vous c'est peut-être pardon monsieur
d'Estival que on avait un nombre à
partir de 507h de gens qui soudainement
pardon oui c'est ça partez au Bamas non
moi je suis étonné dans la société dans
lequelle on est en statistique cien de
formation et sociologue cet effet de
seuil on ne tient pas compte de cela moi
je crois qu'on on est dans une société
c'est la même chose pour d'ailleurs le
calcul des impôts je crois qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une continuité faut arrêter
avec des seuils qui sont irrémédable
pourquoi quelqu'un qui a fait 500 heur
n'aurait pas d'ouverture de droit et
pourquoi quelqu'un qui en ferait 600
n'auraiit pas à proportion à prorata
moins d'indemnité je crois que on crée
des seuils et c'est les seuils qui
créent la difficulté moi j'aimerais
savoir combien les 10 % de population
d'intermittent qui sont en dessous du
seuil de 507 qui serait par exemple
entre 450 he et 507 he combien manque de
possibilités d'indemnité voilà je crois
que on a un système qui fonctionne par
cliquet toute la construction
statistique dans ce pays d'ailleurs dès
qu'on parle d'entreprise on a des
catégories quel que soit le secteur
moins de 5 salariés moins de 25 salariés
moins de 50 on l'applique de manière
systématique et je crois que oui il y a
des gens qui se battent d'arrachepied
pour arriver à faire leur 550 seur et
ils le font parce que c'est un métier
difficile où effectivement les heures de
répétition très souvent ne sont pas
salarié si on veut bien faire ce métier
si on veut être par exemple un bon
acteur et bien euh on bénéficie du temps
c'est pas pour effectivement partir au
bas àamass ou profiter de d'intérêts
sociaux par ailleurs et plus
généralement je voudrais revenir sur
cette notion qu'on a évoqué de projet et
en France on refuse de penser des
contrats de projet je viens de terminer
un gros rapport sur l'économie du jeu
vidéo quand vous rencontrez les
entrepreneurs du monde du jeu vidéo
aujourd'hui il y a des projets de 1 an
et demi à 3 ans ce qui fait que on a du
mal à embaucher des gens en durée
indéterminée parce que il y a ce qu'on
appelle communément en anglais le crunch
time c'estàd des périodes ben il y a un
creux et ça coûte très très cher
d'embaucher des gens à durée
indéterminée donc on ne s'en sort pas
avec les CDD d'autant que ces projets
c'est exactement comme quelqu'un qui
monte une pièce du de théâtre qui signe
pour 50 représentations et puis la pièce
a du succès bien on propose de prolonger
de 50 on sait pas au départ où on va et
on a un système français qui est pas
particulièrement lourd si on veut créer
une Flex sécurité qui soit adapté aux
enjeux de l'emploi de notre époque il
faut aussi qu'on accepte de repenser la
réalité de chacun des secteurs moi je
travaille notamment dans dans dans le
contexte de la culture beaucoup en
comparaison avec ce qui se passe au
Canada ou au Québec et je peux vous dire
les industries culturelles hein
d'ailleurs les ARS du cirque fonctionne
pas seulement parce qu'il y a des
subventions et des crédits d'impôt c'est
aussi parce qu'on a su adapter les
moyens la protection sociale à la
réalité de la vie économique de ces
entreprises et qu'on est dans un pays où
c'est tout ou rien c'estàd soit entre le
cded reconductible en permanence et le
le le le
CDI auquel on ne peut pas toucher bien
on n plus adapté à des logiques c'est
pour ça que la réflexion qu'on doit
avoir c'est un quelle logique plutôt
qu'un seuil invariable de 507 he est-ce
qu'on peut avoir des ouvertures de droit
en dessous de 507 he à partir peut-être
d'un seuil minimal de 300 he et comment
au-delà de 700 he euh on peut aussi
défalquer un certain nombre en
considérant que les gens atteint un
revenu ou une capacité de revenu
suffisante pour moins faire appel à la
solidarité interprofessionnelle voilà je
vous remercie merci pas d'autres
questions issues des parlementaires
alors on vous a interrogé sur les femmes
intermittentes sur les agents de Pô
emploi et leur maîtrise des textes sur
le secteur des abus
sur les gens qui manquent de très peu en
raison d'un faible manque d'heur le
fameux seuil et sur l'économie sociale
de politique qui fonctionne au projet on
demandait tout de suite la parole
Monsieur David Virville et Monsieur
Peskine monsieur de Virville ben on suit
toutonde tout le monde
allez-y non je voulais
simplement essayer de de d'expliciter
l'angle que j'ai utilisé tout à l'heure
contenu de ce qui s'est
dit la première chose que j'ai dit c'est
que notre analyse ne conduit pas du tout
à la conclusion qu'il est illégitime
qu'il y ait un régime spécifique pour
les les intermittents et ce qui a été
dit sur le travail par projet j'y suis
particulièrement sensible il se trouve
qu'il y a maintenant quelques années
dans une autre avec une autre casquette
j'avais proposé avec un succès modéré de
définir un contrat de projet bon donc je
n'ai rien contre et comme j'ai essayé de
le préciser la Cour des comptes ne
s'étonne pas du tout que ce
régime parce qu'il y a quand même une
autonomie de ce régime cont tenu de la
nature des contrats qui sont impliqués
que ce régime soit en déficite comme
l'annexe 4 du régime d'assurance chômage
en revanche moi je me permets une
intervention peut-être un peu plus
politique le point ce qui doit être un
point de vigilance c'est dans quelle
mesure ce régime dont nous constatons et
tout à fait d'accord avec Vincent
d'tival qu'il est
particulièrement décalé dans ses
composantes et dans ses paramètres par
rapport aux autres régimes concernant
les précaires dans quelle mesure ce
régime
peut-être un encouragement à la
précarité c'est-à-dire un régime qui
n'est plus un régime qui
défend et qui protège mais un régime qui
suscite la précarité et moi je me
permets d'appeler votre attention
regarder les statistiques dont nous
disposons qui sont maintenant fines et
détaillés on constate on observe sur le
marché du travail des comportements dans
lequel il y a un effet propre du régime
qui suscite la précarité et qui peut
même parfois je je je dis les choses
franchement pour que le le le débat
puisse se prolonger qui dans certains
cas enferme dans la
précarité quand on est dans une
situation comme celle-là qui se traduit
aussi et là permettez-moi de le dire
parce que c'est quand même le rôle du
magistrat des comptes qui se traduit
aussi par des déficits c'estàd quand les
déficits sont corrélés avec une
précarité qui est en partie suscité et
qui peut représenter une forme
d'enfermement du point de vue des
salariés concernés
je pense qu'à ce moment-là il y a il y a
de la marge pour améliorer le
fonctionnement du système c'est-à-dire
le rendre moins déséquilibré sur le plan
des finances mais aussi le rendre plus
protecteur pour les salariés
concernés merci Monsieur
Peskine alors d'abord pour répondre à
l'intervention tout à l'heure le contrat
d'usage est une forme de contrat de
projet c'est en tout cas ça s'appelle un
contrat d'objet mais en réalité il a
bien la nature d'un contrat de projet et
il se trouve que contrairement à
d'autres branches que vous évoquiez
monsieur sénateur nous nous avons en
réalité dans No dans nos dans nos
secteurs économiques nous avons la
possibilité d'ajuster l'emploi à l'UR du
projet je voudrais insister d'ailleurs
sur le fait que contrairement à ce qu'on
croit souvent la durée de ces projets
parfois très longues les les les
personnes qui travaillent par exemple
sur une série d'animation pour la
télévision qui sont des séries par
exemple de 26 x 13 minutes peuvent avoir
des contrats d'objets de 2 ans et demi
parce que le temps de fabriquer cette
série c'est 2 ans et demi ça n'en est
pas moins un objet parfaitement fermé
quand la série sera fini il y aura pas
de jusqu'à ce qu'une autre série soit
mise en œuvre par par l'entreprise il y
aura pas de travail donc c'est pas cette
notion de contrat d'objet on l'a je
crois qu'il faut le dire et le problème
n'est pas de la voir parce qu'on l'a le
problème et ça monsieur a raison le
problème c'est de savoir si on en abuse
ça c'est une vraie question mais le fait
qu'on l'a et il faut il faut dire que
les employeurs et je crois les salariés
parce qu'il faut pas non plus présenter
le monde du spectacle comme un monde
absolument tragique c'est quand même
aussi un métier formidable qu'on fait
les uns et les autres les salariés
eux-mêmes vivent ce métier on l'a vu
d'ailleurs d'une autre manère tout à
l'heure il y a des difficultés il y a la
précarité il y a des choses pénibles
mais globalement c'est quand même on
fait un métier par passion et d'ailleurs
il faut de la passion pour le
faire alors je voudrais revenir un tout
petit peu sur cette notion de de
statistique vous avez raison sur
leseffet de seuil en même temps je vois
pas bien comment on peut faire autrement
mais c'est pas dans le sens où
monsieurville le disait tout à l'heure
qu'on a un effet de seil c'est vers le
bas pas vers le haut et effectivement
qu'est-ce qu'on observe je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure qu'il y avait 265000
personnes qui avaient des qui avaient au
moins un contrat d'usage dans l'année
d'une année courante il y en a 125000
qui ont moins 25 he de travail C 125000
personnes on peut coner que c'est des
touristes purs ce sont des gens dont la
vraie vie n'est pas dans le spectacle ce
sont par exemple des figurants ou des
gens qui font une intervention à la
radio ou je sais pas un médecin qui
vient parler dans une émission musicale
ce sont des gens dont la l'intervention
dans le spectacle est parfaitement
réelle il sont bien dans le spectacle
mais ce ne sont pas pour l'essentiel des
professionnels du spectacle et puis on a
la 110000 qui sont a-dessus du fameux
seuil de 507 et qui grâce à ce passage
de ce seuil perçoiv des indemnités on en
a donc environ 50000 ce qui est
extraordinairement peu peu entre 25h et
507h donc c'est vrai qu'on a un effet de
seuil mais pas tellement dans le sens où
les gens sont punis en dessous c'est ch
dans le sens o en fait les gens qui sont
susceptibles par la totalité comme ça a
été dit tout à l'heure mais la grande
majorité des gens et ce qui explique
d'ailleurs que dans le cas des artistes
c'est vrai on a une accumulation pas
aussi forte que l'a dit monsieurville
mais une accumulation quand même visible
juste au-dessus du seuil c'est beaucoup
moins vrai sur les techniciens parce que
contrairement à ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure à mon avis certes les
techniciens sont bien entendu des
salariés artistiques ce point n'est pas
en débat mais objectivement la durée de
leur contrat est souvent plus longue il
y a moins de contrat d'un jour pour les
techniciens que pour les artistes par
exemple donc le cumul de contrat
nécessaire à obtenir le seuil n'est pas
de même nature même si c'est vrai que
c'est difficile pour tout le monde n'est
pas de même nature pour les catégories
différentes alors ceci pour dire
qu'effectivement il y a un effet de
seuil je vois sincèrement je vois pas
comment on peut faire autrement cet
effet de seuil compte tenu de la nature
de l'emploi chez nous et parce que
justement il y a des gens qui commencent
avec des durées emploi très courtes est
inévitable il faut qu'on crée et on crée
la créer de la même manière pour la
formation un niveau à partir duquel on
considère que les gens sont ou peuvent
être prêt considérés comme des
professionnels du spectacle
naturellement ce seuil est très injuste
c'est évident vous avez parfaitement
raison les gens qui sont un petit peu en
dessous ne sont évidemment pas des gens
étrangers au monde du spectacle on
devient pas techniquement compétent le
jour où on est passé à 57h ça c'est vrai
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on n' pas
résolu le problème il faut bien qu'on
est une règle du jeu et jusqu'à présent
on nous en a pas proposé d'autres et
tout au plus pourrait-on avoir non pas
la suppression d' effet de seuil mais un
effet de SAS c'est-à-dire comme on a une
petite période dans lequelle ça montré
en charge je suis pas sûr qu'on par
rapport au choc de simplification
quiévoquit votre intervention tout à
l'heure on progresserait beaucoup avec
un effet de ça à la place de l'effet de
seuil mais je crois d'ailleurs pas non
plus je dois vous dire au choc de
simplification mais je crain
malheureusement que c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué et ça va rester
compliqué je voulais simplement dire
ceci sans polémique parce qu'il s'agit
pas tellement de poliquer il s'agit de
comprendre pourquoi on a une situation
qui est celle-là alors je reviens encore
une fois sur cette histoire de de sur ce
que disit Monsieur Deville et sur la
permittence parce que c'est ce qui redit
à chaque fois est-ce qu'il faut punir
les gens qui travaill beaucoup plutôt
les employeurs de gens qui travaillent
beaucoup avec un même employux alors
d'abord ça n'a rien à voir avec lesffet
de seu soyons clair c'est pas du tout la
même question que l' fait de seuil par
hypothèse ces gens-là sont très
a-udessus du seuil on a évoqué tout à
l'heure le chiffre de 900 he c'est pas
des gens qui sont concernés par le seuil
je voudrais rappeler ici que ça va
dépendre du cas vous avez un salarié qui
fait tout qui fait une série qui un
technicien qui travaille dans la la
production d'une série de fiction de 8 x
52 minutes par exemple et qui fait ses
heures supplémentaires et qui pour
lequel on déclare les heures
supplémentaire il va faire 8 ou 900 heur
en 6 mois pour autant il y a aucune
spécificité à son cas si on décidait
qu'il fallait pour autant l'employé 12
mois sur 12 d'abord il serait
obligatoirement licencié au bout d'un an
parce que sauf si la production avait de
nouveau une une série avec la même
besoin la besoin de la même personne
mais ça sera probablement pas le cas et
de toute façon ça marchera pas
multiplier par de le prix de la série
peut-être que c'est ça qu'il faut faire
d'ailleurs à l'arrivée mais c'est c'est
une erreur de penser que parce que cette
personne a fait plus qu'un certain
volume horaire avec un employeur donné
elle relève du concept de permittance
c'est-à-dire d'abus donc il faut si on
veut travailler sur cette question qui
encore une fois n'est pas illégitime il
faut absolument aller beaucoup plus loin
que simplement un effet de seuil d'un
nombre d'heures avec un employeur ça ça
ne suffit pas à caractériser l'abus il
faut peut-être se poser des questions
mais c'est souvent le cas qu'on évoque
c'est souvent celui des des
télédiffuseurs qui encore une fois ne
pèse que peu dans l'emploi
d'intermittent contrairement à ce qu'on
croit moins de moins de 10 % du volume
total de l'emploi d'intermittent mais
qui pèse quand même c'est vrai mais il
faut pas il faut pas comment dire
considérer comme un coupable celui qui
travaille longtemps c'est absurde dans
un dispositif o on veut encourager les
gens à travailler plus longtemps donc il
faut bien comprendre que les dispositifs
ne doivent pas avoir pour conséquence de
dire par exemple à un producteur de
cinéma qui a un film de janvier à
février janvier à avril pardon et un
second film de septembre à décembre
qu'il ne doit pas employer le même
technicien pour le second film que pour
le premier parce que sinon ce technicien
va tomber dans la permittence c'est
c'est ce ce type de difficulté qu'on a
derrière ce terme de permittence il faut
absolument bien comprendre que ce terme
est mauvais parce qu'il traduit des
situations très différentes ENF il est
mauvais si comme le fait la Cour des
comptes on le rattache uniquement à une
notion de volume horaire avec un
employeur c'est le problème est réel
mais la le le l'instrument qui est
proposé est totalement inadéquat bon
passons pas trop de temps làdessus ça
reste un détail ce qui je crois est
important vous dis
c'est t derère c'est vrai que ces
éléments statistiques sont important
et c'est vrai que on a comme ça a été
dit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure aussi par
Monsieur on a maintenant beaucoup plus
d'informations statistiqu depuis cette
année qu'on en a jamais
eu merci Monsieur Laurent je ne vous
avais pas vu
excusez-moi non mais je voulais je
voulais juste réagir à ce que vient de
dire monsieur de Viville sa petite
réflexion politique comme il l'a dit
lui-même parce que je je je pense que
moi ça me hérisse les ch sur la tête
d'entendre dire que ce qui enferme les
gens dans la précarité c'est leur statut
d'une certaine manière enfin ou leur
protection leur maigre
protection face à la précarité comme si
nous parlions de profession où le le
problème auquel nous avons à faire face
serait l'installation dans le confort de
la précarité de toutes ces de toutes ces
de tous ces travailleurs du monde de la
culture donc parler de de de de de de
protection qui aujourd'hui au niveau où
elles sont et on a entendu les les
témoignages sur la difficulté à parvenir
à ça qui installerait dans la précarité
me paraît totalement abusif sauf à ce
qu'on me démontre le
contraire pour ces professions là et
plus généralement d'ailleurs et je pense
que nous sommes au contraire dans des
professions où il y a ces vra
discontinuité de l'emploi mais
permanence de l'activité artistique et
une des questions qui est posée à nombre
d'artistes ou de techniciens c'est de
continuer à être en
permanence des artistes et des
techniciens en permanence dans
l'activité alors qu'ils vivent une
situation d'emploi qui elle est
discontinue et notre devoir je crois et
à
travers ce cette question et peut-être
ça ça devrait nous conduire à réfléchir
à beaucoup d'autres questions sur la
place des activités artistiques dans la
société sur la question de l'emploi dans
ces métiers sur beaucoup d'autres choses
mais ce que nous devrions encourager
c'est justement la
possibilité quelle que soit
effectivement la
discontinuité réelle de ces métiers
parce que effectivement il y a des
activités par projet et cetera de
permettre justement le déploiement
permanent de des des capacité de
création artistique qui demande autre
chose que l'emploi dans un projet donc
tout ce qui permet de favoriser ça est
une bonne nouvelle pour ces activités
qui rappelons-le aussi parce que on ne
peut pas discuter de ça hors de cette
question ne sont pas des des activités
ce sont des activités qui ont une une
place ou qui devrait avoir une place
dans la société j'ai envie de dire alors
là pour le le le confort ou plus
exactement pour employer un mot qu'on
qu'on ose plus employer mais pour le
bonheur collectif de toute la société
qui est à mes yeux
centrale merci Monsieur
desestival merci oui je voudrais alors
pas répondre à la place de Pôle emploi
mais sur des sujets qui ont été évoqués
au sujet de pôleemploi puisque quand
même pour l'emploi met en œuvre une
réglementation qui est définie par les
partenaires sociaux euh et dont l'unedi
est chargé de veiller à la mise en œuvre
donc les les questions qui ont été les
questions qui ont été soulevé évidemment
nous nous intéresse et nous concerne euh
voilà je vais pas nier qu'il y a des
difficultés les les exemples que vous
avez donné que je connais pas dans le
détail mais voilà montre bien qu'il y a
sans doute des difficultés et puis les
les témoignages euh des sénateurs
également le soulignent donc voilà mon
propos n'est pas là euh ce que je
voudrais dire c'est deux choses première
chose c'est que pour l'emploi applique
une réglementation donc euh vous pouvez
pas faire reproche à Pôle emploi de la
manière dont pôleemploi applique la
réglementation qui lui est fixée par
d'autres je je vais je
vais je je vais prendre un exemple que
vous avez pris la question de
l'articulation entre l'assurance et la
solidarité et notamment les règles de
ordination entre les régimes d'assurance
et de solidarité il y a un principe
général c'est que les règles d'assurance
en l'intervention de l'assurance
chôummage et première par rapport à
l'intervention des dispositifs de
solidarité et donc les règles de
coordination que vous avez indiqué sont
justes et répondent à ce principe là
ensuite ce que je voudrais dire
également c'est que les les difficultés
je pense que elles sont également
entendues et que des solutions également
sont apportées il y a plusieurs exemples
que vous avez
cité je voilà où les les questions on
été identifiées parce que vous avez posé
les questions ou d'autres d'autres
représentants ont posé les questions
parce que pô emploi nous les a fait
remonter et des solutions on été
trouvées je prendrai deux exemples vous
avez évoqué les résidenceces d'artistes
nous avons trouvé une solution donc je
sais que le problème a existé par le
passé ce problème à ma connaissance est
aujourd'hui résolu vous avez également
évoqué dans les difficultés de
fonctionnement la
question de la qutité saisissable nous
savons que cette difficulté a
exista nous avons également veillé avec
Pôle emploi à ce que la loi en la
matière soit respectée et donc les
dispositions législatives qui disent
qu'il faut
laisser le minimum vital aux person
qui bénéficient des avocations
deassurance chômage cette règle est
désormais appliquée donc
donciste toujour c'est une r qui qui a
nous savons que ce problème a existé ce
problème a été a été regardé et les
dispositions été prises trè point sur
lequel là aussi je pense qu'il y a des
choses qui sont en cours au niveau de
Pôle emploi c'est la
question euh alors qui a été évoqué par
la Présidente je crois des disparités
géographiques je crois que c'est on sait
bien et tout le monde l'a dit
aujourd'hui qu'on est dans un cadre
réglementaire qui qui est complexe
s'agissant des annexes 8 et 10 pourô
l'emploi on a également conscience et
c'est pour ça que pourô l'emploi a revu
son organisation et en train de
finaliser une centralisation pour avoir
des équipes qui sont spécialisées sur
l'indemnisation des intermittents du
spectacle parce que il faut des gens qui
connaissent leur situation donc pour
l'essentiel des régions maintenant les
dossiers d'indemnisation des
intermittents va être traité de façon
centralisée sur les sauf pour les
quelques régions dans lesquels il y a un
nombre d'intermittents très important
c'est le cas notamment en Île-de-France
euh le dernier point sur lequel je
voulais intervenir au-delà des sujets
donc liés à la manière dont Pôle Emploi
met en œuvre la
réglementation fixée par les partenaires
sociaux question qui a été évoquée
également c'est la question des femmes
intermittentes et des congés
maternité bon je crois que le sujet a
été bien posé a été bien
expertisé je vous rappelle que
s'agissant des dispositions prises par
les partenaires sociaux dans le cadre de
l'indemnisation du chômage une
disposition dérogatoire qui a été prise
pour euh les intermittentes concernées
relevant donc des annexes 8 et 10 qui
fait que euh le temps passé en congé
maternité est assimilé à du temps de
travail ce qui n'est pas le cas pour les
autres professions donc c'est vraiment
une disposition favorable pour les
intermittentes ce sujet euh c'est une
disposition
favorable indemnisé les périodes travern
les périodes de congé maternité sont
prises en compte par l'assurance chômage
comme du temps de travail dès lors oui
dès lors vous avez raison dès lors
qu'elles sont pris en charge par
l'assurance maladie mais donc voilà donc
je crois qu'il y a effectivement un
problème il me semble ce sujet a été
également vu dans le cadre du rapport de
Jean-Patrick Gill il me semble que
l'État a pris des dispositions dans ce
sens-là voilà donc ça reste à suivre
c'est c'est récent ça reste à
suivre ce sujet par ailleurs a fait
l'objet pour l'Unedic d'échange régulier
avec le Défenseur des droits
et donc nous avons examiné les questions
est-ce qu'il y avait discrimination ou
pas nous avons expliqué au Défenseur des
droits quelle était la nature des
dispositions prises par l'assurance
chômage je pense
que la compréhension du
dysfonctionnement plutôt lié au champ de
l'Assurance Maladie qu'au champ de
l'assurance chômage est relativement
bien identifié voilà ce que je voulais
dire merci nous allons terminer cette
table ronde je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur grégois euh à Véronique ravier
et à la présidente du groupe de travail
monsieur
grégois merci oui je voulais revenir sur
la la question de de l'effet de seuil et
du et du levier finalement que que
constitue les changements de de
disposition sur l'éligibilité sur les
règles d'éligibilité alors ce qu'il faut
effectivement savoir c'est que quand on
regarde les les statistiques il est vrai
V que les choses ne sont pas du tout
uniformes d'un côté et de l'autre du
seil évidemment en dessous des 507 he on
trouve beaucoup moins de personnes que
au-dessus simplement ce qu'on comprend
ce qu'on a vu à travers les témoignages
intermittents c'est que ce seuil est
fondamental à à atteindre et que donc il
y a une une lutte permanente tous les
ans pour réussir à atteindre ce seuil
donc c'est assez logique finalement
qu'on a une concentration derrière ce
seuil alors j'ai fait quelques
pour pour alimenter un petit peu le le
le la question du de la 5è piste qui
justement est de de travailler sur le
levier de cette règle de d'éligibilité
j'ai fait une une petite une petite
estimation euh donc il y a plusieurs SC
scénarios qui sont sur la table si
on revenait à 507h en 12 mois avec date
anniversaire on aurait une augmentation
qui finalement ne serait pas très élevée
puisque comme je vous l'ai dit derrière
la Bar des 507 actuells il y a pas pas
grand monde donc l'ordre de grandeur
c'est disons 5 % de d'intermittent
indemnisé en plus en revanche si on
prend les les les données euh de
l'Unedic donc de 2011 si on revenait
alors en 12h en 12 mois sur 650 ou 700
he on obtiendrait les résultats suivants
sur 700 he euh on toucherait les 2/3 de
l'annexe 10 et 1/3 de l'annexe 8 sur le
donc je vous donne des ordres de de
grandeur vous avez les vous avez les les
données précises euh dans les
publications de de lunedic ceon appelle
les allocataires indemnisés en auud des
annexes 8 et 10 en 2011 sur l'hypothèse
de 650 he les ordres de grandeur c'est
25 % de euh l'annexe 8 qui serait exclu
et la moitié de l'annexe 10 donc vous
voyez que c'est très sensible
précisément parce que il y a une forte
concentration euh du côté de de ce seuil
de de 507 he alors pour simplement pour
le l'origine historique de de ces 57
elle provient de des combats de la CGT à
la fin des années 70 qui militaent pour
avoir un droit équivalent au régime
général pour les intermittents du
spectacle la convention unedque de
1979 a permis cette victoire de la CGT
qui a fait passer le seuil des 500ateurs
de enfin le seuil d'éliggibilité de 14
40 he par an à 520 he 520 he c'était 13
semaines c'est-à-dire 3 mois à 40 he qui
était la durée légale du travail à
l'époque et quand la durée légale du
travail est descendue à 39h on est
descendu à 507 c'està dire 13 x 39 qui
correspond effectivement à 13 semaines
travaill à 39h on n pas procédé de la
même manière quand on est passé au au
35h et on a pas non plus suivi le le
régime général ce qui aurait évidemment
aujourd'hui pour effet de descendre
drastiquement ce ce ce seuil
euh alors sur les effets de ces
leviers la leçon un petit peu de la
réforme de 2003 c'est que la réforme de
2003 a essentiellement joué sur ce
levier en durcissant le le seuil
d'éligibilité ce qui s'est passé après
2003 ça a été un choc assez important il
y a beaucoup de gens qui ont ét exclus
mais en réalité il y a eu une forme il y
a eu des formes d'adaptation
d'adaptation dans la douleur mais
d'adaptation autrement dit on a exclu
des intermittents qui sont en réalité
revenus l'ambition à l'époque affichée C
c'était de de séparer disons de 30 % des
des intermittents et en réalité il n a
pas eu du tout de baisse donc ce levier
de l'éligibilité des règles
d'éligibilité il a des conséquences
fortes sur disons le
rapport au travail à l'emploi des
intermittents sur leur sentiment de
précarité qui va être accentué par la
difficulté à atteindre le seuil mais il
il a pas d'effet économique
démographique de démographie
professionnelle très
très fort al je voudrais avant que
monsieur Virville s'en aille peut-être
répondre sur la la question de de
l'effet du du du régime qui résulterait
de de la précarité enfin la précarité
résulterait du du régime c'est une une
théorie qui est en en vogue c'est-à-dire
c'est le ce que les économistes
appellent la théorie de l'agence une
asymétrie d'information l'assurance qui
n'a pas les informations et on aurait
une entente entre les employeurs et les
intermittents qui ferait payer
externaliserait sur l'assurance euh le
le une partie de de leur coût salariauxx
et donc ça générerait de la précarité
puisqu'on aurait intérêt à être plus
précaire alors la théorie
est bon est intéressante mais cette
théorie elle a été testée notamment elle
été testée sur le les intermittents et
ce qu'on a observé sur le long terme sur
les séries de long terme en partant de
début des années 80 jusqu'à euh aux
années 200020 c'est qu'en réalité on n
pas constaté ce qu'on aurait constaté si
cette théorie était vraie si cette
théorie était vraie on aurait vu dans le
budget de chacun des intermittents petit
à petit se décaler euh avoir un recours
de plus en plus fort à l'assurance
chômage que dans le budget des
intermittence on on soit passé disons de
90 % d'emploi et 10 % de chômage à petit
à petit 80 70 % et cetera et que pour
chaque intermittent on devrait observer
un report sur l'assurance chômage or
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on constate on
regarde les séries de long terme ce
qu'on voit les séries de de lunedic on
voit que le le coût d'un intermittent
est extrêmement stable dans le temps ce
qui a fait donc un intermittent dans le
budget d'un intermittent l'Unedic ne
représente pas l'indemnisation chômage
représente une part qui est
remarquablement stable ce qui veut dire
que le les coûts ont augmenté par le
nombre d'intermittents le nombre
d'intermittents qui sont rentrés dans le
dans le dans le système des années
depuis les années 80 et pas du tout par
un report de chacun des intermittents
sur le sur l'assurance
chôumage merci Madame
ravier dans ce que Monsieur des sttival
sur ce que Monsieur Destival dit donc
vous-même vous dites oui vous constatez
on l'a dit différence de traitement sur
territoire donc il y a bien
interprétation des règles la règle est
la même pour tous les règles sont les
mêmes pour tous donc il y a quand même
une politique interne suivant les
agences suivant parce qu'il y a des
indicateurs faut faire du chiffre et le
chiffre il va pas dans le sens pour les
gens il va dans le sens des agences et
du coup c'est au détriment des personnes
euh sur la le la PS et la FD là faudrait
qu'on se positionne à quoi elles servent
j'ai juste envie de dire ça ces
allocations sont là si d'un seul coup
euh c'est la bascule au régime général
voilà donc je repose la question euh
et dans ce que vous dites non la règle
n'est pas appliquée il y a l'accord
d'application numéro 1 où normalement la
réglementation la plus favorable doit
être appliqué aussi à la personne avant
la bascu donc ce sont voilà ce sont des
tas de petites entorses l'instruction
dont j'ai parlé c'est une instruction
interne àô l'emploi qui ven il y a une
politique interne àô l'emploi qui est là
qui vient influer et donc non on est
tous d'accord qu'il y a une
réglementation mais nous sur le terrain
ce qu'on voit c'est que on ex
par des tas de petites de de de petits
dépis phénomènes on exclut les gens
voilà pour le compte-rendu de de la
commission quand vous vous rapportez des
anecdotes mais en dehors de ça vous
citez des circulaires intern et cetera
dont vous déplorez bienvenue à la
communication écrite de ces textes
oui je vous avais déjà remis le rapport
cap vous les avez M C c'est la même
règle he c'est je reviens on jongle à
part cette instruction là que nous on
vient de découvrir parce que aussi les
problématiques arrivent par vague et
c'est ça que je veux bien vous signaler
s'il y a des vagues c'est qu'il y a des
modifications il y a donc des
instructions soyons bien clair sinon les
phénomènes arriverit pas par vague donc
nous les découvrons comme vous au fur et
à mesure et nous cherchons voilà voilà
je voulais conclure moi sur un point
très court je voulais conclure sur un
point très court sur cette histoire qui
concerne les effets de seuil euh et donc
nous évidemment la coordination a tour
été favorable à assouplir les conditions
d'entrée on et on a travaillé de manière
générale à tous les endroits où il y a
des effets de seil parce que à chaque
fois qu'il y a des effets de seil ça
pose 10000 problèmes c'est on va
bidouiller pour le dépasser pour être en
dessus pour êre en dessous d'où le
calcul de plafonnement cumule indemnité
celui de la coordination qui peut
sembler compliqué mathématiquement mais
une fois que c'est mis dans la machine
ça marche tout seul euh ou qui a un
système qui essaie d'éviter tous les
effets de seuil comme pouvait l'être la
franchise ou quelqu'un qui une fois dans
sa vie gagne beaucoup d'argent et qui en
règle générale gagne moins tout d'un
coup se voit pendant un an coup ses
allocations donc on a travaillé un
plafond de cumul qui va lisser le plus
possible voire sur 2 ans hein ces
moments où le
salarié on estime qu'il a gagné
suffisamment et qu'il n'a plus besoin
d'allocation chômage car pour nous les
assédiques ne sont pas pour financer les
salariés de luxe en aucun cas donc se
pose
la question politique fondamentale
puisqu'on a parlé de politique en 2003
la bascule qui a eu c'est bien d'un
système qui était à égalité
redistributif assuranciel à un système
quasiment strictement
assurantiel donc les mesures telles que
le plafond de cumul pourraient résoudre
ces questions très compliquées de la
permittance euh à savoir que les gens
qui gagnent beaucoup qui travaillent
beaucoup bah au bout d'un moment ils
cotisent mais ils ont moins besoin
d'indemnité que ceux qui sont au seuil
de ces 507urs tous les ans c'est assez
simple à comprendre mais il y a un grand
enjeu politique car Donis kestler en
2002 président d'Axa un dépenseur de la
refondation sociale et notamment celle
de de la réforme de l'Unedic hein
déclaré haut et fort il y a des
centaines de milliards d'argent à
récupérer dans la SC dans tous ces
endroits appelle de l'argent passif qui
ne rentre pas dans l'économie qui ne
rentre pas chez AXA hein et donc le but
quand même de ces réformes est de faire
calquer le plus possible ce qui était un
système public vers un régime
strictement assurentiel c'est ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire hein et de virer
à terme ces annexes 8 et 10 car pour les
le MF qui se bat pour une flexibilité
sans sécurité il est totalement
intolérable que perdure un système dans
cette économie de de plus en plus
flexible qui soit autant à l'avantage
des salariés et ça monsieur gotis
souvagiaac n'a aucun problème à le dire
publiquement en pleine négociation une
édique qu'on soit bien d'accord
là-dessus donc c'est pas qu'un problème
au bout d'un moment de compétence ou
d'incompétence c'est vrai que la fusion
pour l'emploi quand on veut tuer son
chien on l'accuse de l'arrache hein
c'est voilà mais mais ce n'est pas qu'un
problème voilà de à un moment il y a pas
que des problèmes techniques il y a un
vrai choix politique assuranciel
redistributif et ça mieur les
parlementaires je pense que c'est c'est
un sujet qui vous concerne
particulièrement c'est pour ça que nous
sommes là bien je vous fais une petite
interruption de débat parce que nous
avons nous sommes en commission en
commission des affaires culturelles et
nous avons d'autres travaux à faire
c'est très bref je vais vous prendre une
minute nous devons
nommer des membres de la Commission au
Conseil supérieur des programmes de
l'Éducation
nationale en collaboration après
concertation des groupes nous devons
nommer deux hommes une
femme je vous propose que la Commission
nomme monsieur Le Gendre monsieur manier
et moi-même y a-t-il un scénario
alternatif non
non alors les membres désignés par
l'assemblée nationale sont par décret de
la volonté du gouvernement et de
Monsieur payon deux femmes et un homme
et cette méthode de décret pour flécher
qui fait la fille j'en ai fait des
remontrances puisque je pense que c'est
susceptible d'être instrumentalisé
éventuellement je dis pas que c'est le
cas cette fois-ci mais le Parlement
souhaite se débrouiller lui-même quand
on lui demande de faire la parité voilà
madame la Présidente vous n'êtes pas en
mesure de N communiquer de nos cèges ce
qui fait je peux pas vérifier que notre
groupe politique puisse être être
représenté je les ai pas c'est quand
même je proteste vivement madame la
Présidente c'est
noté bien je considère donc votre
assentissement votre approbation et les
protestations de Madame Gontier Morin au
nom de son groupe et nous reprenons nos
travaux et je donne la parole à marieon
Blondin voilà merci madame la
Présidente avant de passer à la deè me
table ronde concernant plutôt les
mesures d'accompagnement et cette
écosystème de de la culture juste
peut-être pour information aux collègues
qui ont entendu parler de guuso et qui
peuvent s'interroger sur ce que c'est il
s'agit d'un guichet unique pour le
spectacle
vivant à direction des organisateurs
occasionnel de spectacle vivant donc
voilà pour votre information et et deuxè
point effectivement dans la liste des
pistes de
réflexion j'avais
indiqué le nombre d'heures et et et ce
seuil et j'avais évoqué aussi la dacte
anniversaire et de passer de 10 mois et
10 mois et demi à 12 mois et euh je qui
assurait une visibilité euh plus plus
simple et qui évidemment dans cette
logique de travail global de l'assurance
chômage je dis bien global pas
simplement concernant le dérogatoire
euh nous avons fait une sorte de
proportionnalité pour passer des 507 he
ça fait temps divisé par 10 mois et 10
mois et demi donc ça fait temps si nous
ramenons ça sur 12 mois
et nous avons
donc élaborer ce calcul à partir de la
durée légale du travail qui est de 16
1607 he en France et puis nous l'avons
ramené à
cette
proportionnalité voilà mais dans dans
tout cela don nous avons entendu les
propos des intermittents qui ont accepté
de témoigner qui vous disaient que
c'était fort difficile d'arriver au
507ur pour certains d'entre eux et nous
avons pris en compte aussi un autre
dispositif qui a été abordé mais mais
sans plus
qui permet justement d'assurer des cours
alors on a entendu le Conservatoire mais
également dans les établissements
scolaires et je fais ainsi le
rapprochement avec la réforme des
rythmes scolaires alors ça ça va encore
dépendre des territoires des endroits où
nous
sommes et de la réglementation
aussi voilà d'accord mais euh voilà dans
certains territoires ça fonctionne et
bien avec des euh intermittent du
spectacle qui assure un projet sur euh
moi je connais à peu près un trimestre
ce qui est déjà euh une approche assez
intéressante et donc il y a ce volet
supplémentaire d'heure que nous avons
proposé d'agrandir et de passer jusqu'à
90h au lieu des 55 he euh voilà pour
pouvoir
ensuite venir
compléter l'évolution
des des heures jusqu'à 600 600 he pour
12 mois voilà c'était nos
euh des pistes de de réflexion qui
demandent encore à être travaillé j'ai
bien compris euh
voilà voilà donc pour cette table ronde
portant sur les enjeux de
l'intermittence dans le domaine culturel
une table ronde menée par la commission
de la culture et qui s'est déroulée la
semaine dernière au Sénat vous pouvez
bien sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes
les tables-rondes et toutes les
auditions sur notre site
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire 24h Sénat à
19h Delphine Girard très bonne journée
sur les chaînes
parlementaires